Wait a second.
I'm not ready at all.
I'm not!
Eh?
I'm not...
Ah!
Eh?
Why can't I hear anything my headphones?
Eh!
Are you guys hearing me?
Ah!
Hmm?
They weren't plugged in.
I'm
sorry, I gotcha, I gotcha, I gotcha, I gotcha.
I'm sorry, that was me grabbing my controller.
I'm so...
Today, holy moly.
Hello, hello, hello.
Hi, hi.
She's trying her best.
I am.
I'm truly trying my best.
Yori lover.
Welcome to my booshup.
Thank you.
Thank you, thank you.
No, it wasn't disconnected.
Well, what disconnected was the controller because I grabbed them.
So...
I grabbed it off the stand.
So I guess it disconnected from the stand.
But it connected to my computer.
Was that your concert this morning?
They were super cute and evil ghosts.
Got some echo.
Two audio inputs or maybe speakers on side?
Let's have...
Two?
Don't hear any echo?
You might have another window open, Duargo.
You might have a second tab open.
I've done that before.
Or I'm like, why is there an echo?
Been there.
Yeah, this morning I had...
I was at a convention.
U.S.
Idol Festival.
I performed.
for a good happy birthday happy happy birthday happy happy birthday i performed i did a concert and then i just got done with meet and greets like two hours ago no yeah uh wait an hour ago ish hour and a half ago and then i so basically it was the first time i've ever done the meet and greets like this that's probably it thanks for the tech support boy Of course!
I'm pretty tired, yeah.
But that's okay.
Minky fart.
It's my B-Day today.
Yuri lover.
Happy, happy birthday!
Why do I fart?
No fart.
No.
But, um, the mean greets, I would do the mean greets, and then we would take a picture, and then afterwards I would decorate the picture.
picture so it looks like so then they would print it out on a checkie and um and uh what was i saying um so that took me about an hour afterwards because i was like decorating all of the all of the checkies so that's why i was like oh i finished like an hour and a half ago for the me and Greed,
but then I had homework.
I had homework, so...
Metal Gear in concert was awesome!
Oh my gosh, Roku Yod!
I'm glad you went.
I hope it comes to somewhere near you in the near future so you can go.
I've been able to go at least to the one in Japan.
And I cried, cried, cried, cried, cried.
So...
Nah, well, thank you so much for the Toa Wari Gifted.
Thank you!
Yeah, I'm a little bit tired, but I'm also excited to i didn't want to put up push off um beating silent hill because i was like oh my gosh it's it's been it's been long enough wait over
left mint my oh she right mint is pretty good too i guess didn't win the meet and greet lot over had a lot of fun at the concert you know you know actually i saw you before the concert you were standing towards the front by the stage And I saw you and I was like,
I recognize that guy.
Thank you so much.
Thank you.
Yeah, I saw you there.
Thank you so much.
Saw the clip of you singing in the chant from the crowd.
Oh, wait, I didn't actually watch the clip yet.
So, thanks so much for making me tear up watching your performance.
Reminds me of a simpler times as a VTuber fan.
Thank you.
Hope you had a happy Halloween, Vinky, going to a party.
Whoa, have fun, Maddie.
Have fun at your party.
Yeah, actually, that song was a last-minute inclusion.
I was going to switch out another song for it, and then I was like, wait a second, if I switch out songs, I'll have a lot of time left over, so I decided that I would just do both.
Um...
You know...
I...
I was just like, well, you know...
But here's my thought process.
The concert was very early in the morning.
So I wanted to maybe give a little treat to people who woke up early and got there early.
Just to come and see me, I really appreciated it.
So...
And then also, um, it's not a song that I will sing probably ever again.
So, but was it truly a little treat?
Truly a little treat.
Um, but yeah, I hope you guys appreciated it.
But yeah, yeah, I also wanted to say something else because I feel like, how do I say, I feel like I owe you guys a bit of an apology.
You guys are going to be like, don't apologize for you too, but, you know, I just want to say like, um, my, a lot has been going on behind the scenes, like a lot of just stuff that's being planned and also just other stuff.
and so my mental has been kind of like spiraling and i feel like you know i've had it affect my streams a lot lately and um and uh i get especially like brain fogged when i get this way like i i seriously it's hard for me to form coherent thoughts and so um you know sometimes when i get this bad i um i forget i don't it's not that i forget but i lose sight of the fact that um that uh my my number one goal for stream is is just entertainment and so uh um you know usually i'm pretty good about like even if stuff is going on i can just of like flip a switch and be like okay we're going baby let's go but uh lately it's been a little bit harder for me so i apologize um november november definitely november i'm gonna be streaming quite a bit less i'll post my schedule like not a schedule schedule but like kind of a rundown of the month to show you guys um but i'm gonna take the time to like of its work it's not all rest but i'm going to take the time to really like um avoid the burnout that
i am feeling i am coming close to so but also happy november happy november i'm sorry i missed halloween uh for real no need to apologize we would rather you communicate than repress well i don't want to bother anybody with anything, so it's okay.
Take care of my Oshibinto, okay.
I'm trying!
I have bad brainwarp, so.
Yeah.
So, um, hopefully, hopefully.
Hopefully I can this month and next month next month i have a couple days off as well um so by new years we can start all spick and span all shiny and new and hopefully we can bring in 2026 um in a good way i always enjoy your streams but i hope you get the rest you need thank you no i'm sorry some of the stuff though is you know me it's not just it's not just all me taking break it's also some things that i'm working on that will come out eventually so it's non-stop jihongo november ah shumi my scene non-stop nihongo november this and that thank you guys thank you thank you thank you thank you I don't know it's just been like I said usually I can pull myself out of it sometimes I'll like get into a deep funk and it's kind of funny how like my brain works I'll like get into like I will be like yesterday I was like this is so TMI I was like crying the whole day it's so embarrassing I just like couldn't get myself to stop and and uh sometimes like i'll be that way i'll be that way and
then i'll be like and then i'll be like okay like i it's so strange i'll be sitting there crying crying crying and then like five minutes later i'll just sit there and i'll be like okay i'm done feeling bad for myself i'm fine now
a switch like that i'll just be like okay i'm i'm tired of being sorry for myself okay let's yeah it's like a total 180 and i'll be like it's funny because i'll be like totally spiraling like i'll be like nobody likes me everything is terrible i'm just gonna quit it all i'm gonna go move into the woods and never think about anything ever again and then five minutes later
I'm normal now.
Yeah, exactly.
So, sorry that.
I feel like for the past couple of weeks, honestly, I've been like, uh, so, um, foggy-brained.
What I should be is froggy-brained.
You know?
But today, we are finishing Silent Hill F finally.
Oh my gosh, I'm like the slowest person.
I think I'm the only person that hasn't finished this game yet.
So, oh, oh, why am I lagging?
What's happening?
Why am I lagging?
Thank you guys for all this.
Super chance, thank you.
Hold on.
Let me see if there's anything that...
Sorry, I just saw this picture I took.
Of...
Look at this picture I took.
Sorry, whoever this is.
I was taking screenshots of the idol festival stage.
I can't wait to see that picture.
I hope you post it on Twitter later.
I'm
not lagging anymore.
I wonder what happened.
I fixed it.
Wait, what if I click on the game?
Oh, I start lagging again!
Robbie, I thank you!
My super chats aren't working.
Wait, why is the game lagging for me whenever I click on it?
Hold on, I'm gonna close the game.
reopening it.
A Swiss would rather you take time for yourself than know you're struggling just for us.
Well, I have like so much anxiety about it because YouTube is not kind.
I'm like, I'm always like, people, everybody will forget about me.
So it's really hard for me to like take a break.
No, no, no, no, no, no.
Hi!
Huh?
Wait.
When's the last time I played this?
I updated my graphics card.
The la- I think- I updated my graphics card before the last time I played this- oh no.
Wait.
Huh?
What do I do?
Uh oh.
It's okay now because I clicked out of the game.
You'll know when I click into the game.
What do I do?
I mean, I have to switch to...
But the graphics are already down.
They're the same...
They're the same that I had before.
I guess I could turn them down even more, but like...
This sucks!
I shouldn't have to do this!
Balanced?
yeah the resolution is okay honestly if I make it any smaller I won't be able to see the game I've never I didn't have to turn off wallpaper engine before it still didn't work I think updating my graphics card messed everything up this is this is so stinky no way no way
Okay, hold on.
I'm gonna load the game and see if that...
Oh my gosh, it looks so...
It doesn't look bad, but it just looks great.
Wait!
Oh!
Oh my gosh, wait, that did fix it though.
That did fix it.
Why?
I updated my graphics card!
Okay, I'm gonna be honest with you guys.
I updated my graphics card to try for the VR stream.
And, um, the time...
I hadn't updated my graphics card.
card in over a year.
Until like last week.
It was working fine.
I didn't need to.
Yeah, if it isn't broke.
And clearly, clearly, I made the right decision because I just had to turn down everything to get myself to work.
What the heck?
Uh.
It honestly isn't that unusual because so many updates just break everything.
Hmm.
This is the worst.
I'm so mad right now.
But we, we, a baby's gotta do what a baby's gotta do.
I also updated mine like a week ago and I regret it.
I think I'll roll back.
Oh, oh, oh, oh.
That spooked me.
okay let's see what were we doing go through the oh yes we're going home how could i forget we're going home we got the drip i really miss my yeti arm though i think i got everything over here it's even like stuttering a little bit this is crazy crazy work right now Eko really is a ghost then.
Sweet home, Ebisugaoka.
Yes, it's this way.
I see this little black spot right there.
I imagine we probably...
Wait, we probably have to go that way.
And go around.
Because this looks like it leads to nothing.
The staircase in the middle?
I'll try lowering the resolution.
But you guys, I won't be able to see.
Oh, oh, oopsie.
I didn't mean to do that.
Wait, sorry.
What?
Oh, wait, how is that?
Big.
Follow the bouncing bunny tail.
Okay, why did it make the window bigger?
I don't want to go that small.
here so I can see.
That looks a bit better.
Oh, that's better.
That's better.
Oh, Kali!
Oh, no, it's a titty monster.
Oh!
Sorry, hold on.
I'm trying to fix everything now.
Oh my gosh.
That, uh, changed my...
Okay.
Um...
Shoot.
Okay.
trying to remember how to fight big big fight small fight dodge lock on what did this do okay uh we'll stick with our crowbar i like that i was walking around the city last night and i ran into someone just as hinako for halloween she had the pipe and rip sleeve and everything oh i've seen several hinako cosplayers like jp idols have been like cosplaying her for halloween and stuff Panda thank you so much for the 20 gifted thank you I don't want to fight this thing maybe I should just run oh oh golly do I have to see I'm think right there oh wait what's this another kitchen knife we can replace our old kitchen knife
I do think about leaving everything behind and moving into the woods sometimes.
But if I ever did, I could have probably Yoshi you.
It's because, for me, I'm really...
This is, like, I chose the worst thing ever.
I'm just really not good with...
With all, like, the attention sometimes.
Okay, I'm just gonna run.
I'm gonna run for it.
Bye!
Wait, is this the...
Is this the wrong way?
Oh, gosh.
Oh, my God.
No, no, no, no, no, no, no.
Oh, wait.
Where am I?
Oh, gosh.
Wait.
Where am I supposed to go?
Ah!
Oh, God.
Wait.
No, please.
Is this a...
Ah, jeez!
Okay.
Um...
Alright.
Uh...
Please do not...
Where do I go?
This is a boss fight of sorts, yes.
Okay, so I have to...
to.
Okay.
Yeah, I don't think it'll...
Oh, I see.
It won't clear up until I do kill it.
That's messed up.
Come here.
Oh!
Yeah, come here!
Don't go that way.
Then I confess.
Oh!
I dodged but not fast enough, I guess.
My bad.
I like how the mannequin is just, like, chilling over there.
Wait, did that get me?
Don't blame.
Come here!
Wait.
Oh, so nasty.
Slorpin'.
Slorpin.
Oh, my thing is about to break, so...
Let's actually...
Go to the axe, maybe.
Stop it.
Stop going...
Oh, she...
It's pushing the mannequin.
Why are you leaving?
Where are you going?
It's just fading out.
Can you come here or something?
I don't want you attacking me.
Two in one!
Two in...
Oh, I have no.
Are you broken?
What's wrong?
Ah, nice.
Nice, nice, nice.
Maybe...
Actually, I think that hit me.
Oh, we got her.
Okay, yay.
So lame.
Forcing me to fight that thing.
Hold on.
Now I can check around.
though see if there's any stuff maybe i think hold on uh oh my bad um what's the button no why am i why can't i remember how to see what might oh here we go okay okay we have one toolkit my brother i think i should use it on my knife i think i should use yeah okay i'm gonna use it Yeah,
I love a drink from the good drink machine.
Oh yeah.
That's a good drink.
Nothing.
Stingy.
Stingy game.
Does the game...
Oh, return to Shimi's in residence.
Does the game look bad?
Does it still look okay that I lowered the quality on it?
What is this?
Oh, potatoes.
Potatoes.
Potatoes and molasses.
Looks okay?
Okay, go ahead.
I'm gonna turn back my...
Roll back my graphics card update.
I will not be held back.
You cannot...
You cannot hold this back.
Mama?
Lembo.
More soon.
More soon?
Really?
Good morning.
Good morning, everyone.
Today was my birthday!
Somebody, wait, your birthday is on Halloween?
That's so awesome.
Happy birthday!
Wait.
I'm hearing sounds from all over.
Spooky.
Well, this seems to be a dead end, but...
Oh my gosh.
I got it.
Wait, what's my health at?
Oh, we're okay.
What does that sound?
What is going...
What's purring?
Here, kitty.
Are you in the house?
I can't...
No, he's gotta be behind the house.
Here, kitty.
Kitty.
The...
It sounds so close.
Is it right behind the door?
Anyway.
Oh!
Oh my gosh.
No!
There's a party!
It's somewhere.
Yeah.
Definitely somewhere.
We're just like, walk.
Wait, so...
Oh, if we go this way, it probably...
It wouldn't make us go that way.
We have to go this way.
Away from the way the mannequins went.
This is not my house.
Up here.
We're going home.
I don't like that.
Oh, I really don't like that.
Oh, oh, okay.
I'm ready.
Ah!
I wasn't ready.
Ouch.
Oh, sheesh.
Oh my gosh, I can't.
I can't.
Oh.
Come on.
Oh, whoops.
Ouch, ow, ow, ow, ow.
Wow!
Yeah, these guys suck.
These guys suck.
Because they'll get you in, like, a chain.
Like, uh...
Oh, I got him, though.
Yippee!
Ah, is this a full heal?
What the?
Wait, my weapon's gonna break soon!
Oh, no!
Wait, where is...
Why...
Why is everything going so wrong?
Eat.
Tool... that looks like a bandage.
I could use a toolbox, like, pronto.
Like, game?
Game, please be kind.
Game.
Game, won't you love me?
Why is the world so cruel?
The tree branch scared me, the leaves.
We're searching.
I got scared by the fog.
Imagine getting scared by fog in Silent Hill.
Okay.
it's like right there we just gotta beat that other guy what's my wait um okay it's like full it'll probably break soon though scary there he is is this the thing that's clicking okay we're like right there hello hello um actually oh my goodness actually what if I just run past you
Goodbye.
Leave.
You!
Sandava beach.
Wait, where's my house?
Here?
What do you expect?
I guess it would be kind of like crazy to go back home and see it all covered up.
It's always the barf.
He's got me sick.
Sick for you, baby.
Anything around?
No monsters hiding in the back of my house, right?
Surely?
But also no items either?
Hinako, what were you doing?
Why weren't you just replacing random?
some pills around your house before you left.
Shirley.
Don't call me Shirley.
In we go.
Aibo?
Onei-chan?
Dereka?
Oh, oh there we go.
Anybody home?
Ojeamasimasu.
Ooh, stanky.
Oh,
safe point.
Moshi mochi.
They're redecorated, remodeled.
It's like the TARDIS.
Oh.
A normal phone call.
Okay.
I don't like that I definitely don't like that I can whoa wait I saw a save point did I not I saw you oh here you are pray pray the fox man away
like a crazy, wait, why are, I can open, oh, it's no good.
Can't do it.
What about in here?
I hear something in here though.
Oh, okay.
Just kidding.
We're safe.
What about this one?
Okay.
It's no good.
Can't do it.
I'm like hearing some sort of cracking.
Freaky.
Oh, that looks like a weapon.
What does this say?
The sword and the fox fought, battling upon a set of scales.
The heavens themselves shuddered at the ferocity of their struggle.
Day by day, oh, day after day, the sun rose behind the fox's back and set behind the swords.
Yet their fight knew no end.
The scales upon which they fought, however, were no more having been destroyed long ago.
so puzzle
no it's a pipe lame lame okay it's no good wait what's this there used to be a calendar here oh I see so I have to find the crests Okay.
There was a...
What was it?
There was a hole here?
It's gone now?
Spooky, spooky.
I don't want anything jumping out at me.
Oh, the pictures...
Her, like, back is all messed up.
This is huge.
Friendly elephant.
Thank you so much for the gift.
Thank you for the gift.
Thank you for the capsules.
Can I have a toolbox, please?
May I have a toolbox?
Shoe is sick.
the head maybe just like me for real for real sorry i know oh there's a calendar calendar placed behind oh placed beside the room at the end of the hallway
two boxes
okay so we're finding that too got it
I hope this part is more puzzle-focused and less fighting.
Hung.
Wait.
Whoa.
Wait, this is so long.
Okay, before we go in there, I do want to kind of...
What were you looking at?
Oh, nothing.
Okay.
I missed that in, like, horror games when the protagonist, when they saw something, they were, like, very blatantly, like...
Stare at it, you know?
Bapap!
Biplele!
Biplep-bap-bap-a-bop-bap-a-bop!
No!
Okay, we gotta go offer some stuff.
Nerd hours.
Let's go offer some Higashi.
Higashi.
Uh, offer.
The Higashi.
Get some faith, baby.
Oh, I have so many bandages.
I just noticed.
Okay.
All right.
And then we'll go get that.
And then we'll offer that as well.
There's nothing in here, is there?
Nothing gonna pop out.
Right?
Here we go and offer.
Codenya, thank you so much for the gift.
Thank you.
car cash.
I'm just gonna save again so I don't have to do all this again.
Oh!
Shirley, it's safe.
Um, I don't think I asked Shirley's opinion.
Okay.
I'm just making sure what.
It's no good.
Oh my gosh.
It's just endless, endless, endless doors.
Nothing?
Oh, that spooked me.
Why give me the option, then?
Like, it's actually rude.
I'm scared to try this door.
Okay.
There's a lot of bottles.
Hey, Minto.
Hi.
Certificate of full payment.
Toshimizu Kanta.
This certificate has been sent to certify that Shimizu Kanta has paid all outstanding loans and is thereby released from any further contractual obligations.
We thank you for your continued patronage.
Okay.
Good job.
Paying off your debt.
A divine water.
Okay, we can go give that away too.
That's what the dad calls these bottles.
Divine water.
Oh, sorry.
I thought, like, blood appeared on the floor?
I was wrong.
I will go in this door.
Don't worry.
I'm just...
You know...
Biddling!
Yeah, fancy way of saying wine.
That's what Matara calls water.
I mean, wine.
Divine water.
Matara calm.
Oh, my gosh.
Maybe...
this loops hopefully from like this hallway that's the hope at least the wine water nah too on the nose whoa is that her that's like a portrait of her wait okay hold on is this oh my gosh okay all
right i'm going around a little bit what's in here it's stuck
So many rooms!
I'm not going into them because I'm...
Oh!
Ah!
Well...
I guess, yeah, we can switch it out.
I'm scared of the rooms.
Because, you know.
I feel like something will happen in there.
Something always happens in a room.
It's not my fault I'm paranoid.
It's because I've learned.
You want to know how I got these scars.
From learning.
Thank you, thank you.
I mean, though, thank you for today.
Even if I couldn't make it, that was a treat.
Thank you!
Oh, oh, oh, see?
Oh, okay.
This is a loop.
though, right?
Okay, yes, it is.
Okay.
This also...
Oh, okay.
Aha, it all connects.
Okay, cool.
We'll just go this way then.
I picked up a note from Hinako.
I'm still alive, but tomorrow I'll make sure you draw your final breath.
I don't care if it's your special day.
From me?
Who am I telling that to?
Such a gangster.
I'll make sure you draw your final breath.
Oh, Romani.
I could sell that.
Aha!
Okay, good.
I wanted to go sell some of this stuff.
Holy moly.
Um.
Is that the only thing I got?
Oh.
I almost want to do some gotcha.
I have no...
It's hard when I have no...
What's it called?
No enna.
To...
Buy upgrades.
As a treat.
Like look!
I'm almost enough to 3,000.
I am at 2,250.
If we just had an Emma, we would be able to...
Emma?
Who's Emma?
Yeah, I won't draw any...
I won't do a gotcha so that maybe we can increase the Emma slot, or the Omamori slot.
Or stamp... I don't know.
I'll figure out something.
I'll decide.
What's wrong with Eee?
Really, what is wrong with that girl?
What's in here?
Any trinkets?
I love trinkets.
Okay, I'm still looking for like three of those things.
What are they?
The three crests.
Halfway to two years!
Thank you!
Oh my gosh!
Thank you so much.
Oh!
My dream.
Ominous photo.
I don't know why, but it appears each photograph can be rotated.
There might be some kind of connection to the writing and the group photo.
My room.
The sword and fox...
Oh yeah, here we go.
Writing on the... here?
Oh no, this is not a group.
Oh, this one.
What is that?
Something was hanging here before.
Alrighty.
They're crossed out.
It's you, girl.
You're crossed out.
I don't know why.
Oh, wait.
Besides the group photo, there is a collection of other photographs.
One seems to be missing, however.
A rather unsettling group photo that hangs in the living room.
It seems someone has taken a marker to it.
Okay.
Maybe I...
Maybe only she's upside down because she's crossed out.
Check out.
Well, there's other places we need to go.
Actually, wait, we're missing a photo.
So, maybe let's go check this room finally.
And also, the bloody axe room.
Okay.
We're running, we're running.
I feel like this area is really gonna make me...
Put my guard down!
Oh my god!
Gosh,
dang it.
Where is she?
I hate.
Yeah, what is going on with your house, huh?
Girl, I have many questions.
Oh my gosh, my shadow scared me.
I shouldn't have gotten into this.
room I made a grave error and I made a lapse in judgment I I screwed up simply I messed up that's not a door I need to catch up and watch part four should I wait to watch the stream Brian as much as I would love you to stick around I think you should I think you should wait to watch I would I'd love to have you here,
but I understand.
Where is she?
Oh, the music is so loud.
Oh, there she is.
Ouch!
Oh my god.
Did I get
her?
Oh, yeah, I did.
Nice.
Okay.
Brian, thank you so much for the vibe.
Good to thank you!
Okay, we found her.
and there's another one oh there's this stinker oh nasty i don't want to deal with you you're gross oh my
knife yeah okay if there's nothing in here i'm gonna scream oh sickle oh i think we could maybe Place the knife with the sickle.
Wait.
No, I'm thinking of...
What was the thing that I had with the scarecrows?
It wasn't the sickle.
There's a crowbar?
Wait, there's there?
Did I miss it?
I can grab the sickle, though.
Oh.
I will come back for it.
Like if my knife breaks, you know.
Or win my knife.
I don't want it to break, though.
I want to find a toolbox before then, you know?
Dang it!
Let's use a bandage.
Lots of weapons.
We only found one.
Oh, no, you're right.
There was more than one.
Yeah, in this puzzle heavy area.
Hey, you're so right.
What's up with that?
And no Emma!
Stingy game.
That area looks so dark and so scary.
Oh!
Art room.
Oh, cute!
So cute.
Letter from a man.
I do not believe there is any reason you should be tied down by your younger self.
Likewise, there is no reason your future self should be constrained by the you you are today.
Thank you, by the way, for the beautiful pressed flower.
It was the first gift I had received from you, and I will surely cherish it.
it until the end of time.
Huh?
Do you eat me this car?
What does that mean?
The Foxman?
Oh, I hear something.
I can't tell if it's like, oh my gosh, it's so scary.
I can't tell if it's like in here.
Okay, it's gotta be down here then.
Oh, I hear him.
You hear him?
I don't want my weapon to break.
You know what?
Maybe I'll use this.
No.
We'll use the axe, I guess.
Oh, light turned on.
It's stuck.
Oh!
Ah!
Ah, dang it!
Ah, geez.
It's okay.
Oh.
Oh, I hate this weapon.
Ow, geez.
Not doing so hot.
You stuck, too?
We're both stuck?
Ow.
My sanity.
Is this gonna blow up, or are you gonna turn into a thing?
What are we gonna do here?
Ow!
Oh, leave me alone.
Oh my
gosh!
There's purple they spawned something.
Oh, okay.
Somehow I dodge that.
Please!
Ouch!
I
think I needed to use it.
Oh dang, this thing's about to die.
Oh come on!
At least the spit hit the wall too.
But that was evil.
Oh, maybe?
Yippee!
Goodbye, Tinny Monster.
I wish I...
Never heard to say that.
I got some chocolate.
Huzzah!
Huzzah indeed!
Wait, is this room again?
Nandato?
Some kudzu.
Um...
Well... I don't really need...
We don't need the kutsu.
I can always come back to it, too.
My axe is about to break.
All my weapons are about to break.
Look at it.
It has like one...
Wait.
It has like one hit on it.
That's crazy.
All my things are about to break for real, though.
It's pretty bad.
There was that room we could I could go into it could I over here is nothing wait unless no oh gosh scared me imagine the cleanup if one of these got into your house I know okay I'm gonna go get the sickle the sickle I think I hear something and the music gets crazy.
I think there's something afoot.
Okay, goodbye kitchen knife.
I hardly knew ye.
Okay.
Oh, wait.
I can open this door.
Against my better judgment.
Oh.
It's a hallway.
Okay.
What is this?
And Emma!
Oh my gosh!
We got one!
I think that's the lamp that's making the noises, but I don't like it.
Okay.
Let's go, baby.
Actually, let's go save baby.
Yeah.
Let's save baby.
Okay.
And then I...
I will save maybe for the another Omamori slot.
Baby.
Ouch, hold on.
Let me put in an eyedrop, please.
Baby, baby.
No health?
Well...
I feel like I've increased my health already before I don't know why my one eye is like so dry okay um so that leads into another hallway oh my gosh this place I haven't even got it you know what let's go over here let's just get it out of the way it's spooky scary I don't like it it's really dark and I know there's a monster here because the music goes crazy
What's here?
Oh!
What is it?
I think I hate these guys.
Yes, I hate this guy.
Oh, no talk!
Can I sneak up on him?
Oh!
Yeah!
That was so clean.
Wowie.
Good job, Watashi!
Alright.
All those doors are no good.
This looks like an exit.
This looks like it goes outside.
Let's go get rid of the...
Wait, what's the chocolate?
Max sanity?
Eat the chocolate.
Let's eat it.
Delicious.
Does this go outside?
No.
Oh, why would it do that?
Of course not.
Wait, what?
Does someone come excuse me this is my home oh picture of me i can't remember when this was taken though
i do look at it oh scoob we gotta get rid of something no kids came by yesterday so now all this chocolate is mine let's go you don't need that many first Yeah, but I'm not going to throw one away.
The Yokan, I think it would be the best bet.
Or the Higashi.
Let's go with Higashi.
I never use it.
There's two of them, but that's okay.
I don't know what to...
But, uh...
Oh, more capsules.
Um...
I've heard that a lot recently though that people got a ton of...
Holy, okay.
So I could not see at all what I was doing.
I was just... I was just swinging it.
I could not tell at all what was happening.
I just did it.
Well, we got the painting we needed.
Or the picture, whatever it was.
Okay.
Enshrine.
You.
We just need...
Wait.
I could offer Adade.
Actually, let's offer, like, all of them.
Just ten more!
Oh, hold on for now, though.
I want to save.
Okay.
But what Omamori should I equip?
I wonder.
I'm in Osaka, and yesterday I found an idol festival in the park near the castle!
I watched some of the performances, and they were awesome.
The audience is great, too.
Complete with live sticks and otage.
It was really cool.
Let's go!
Sounds fun.
Oh, I guess I just forgot to...
Wait, it says I can enter there, though.
Hmm.
Mysterious.
Curious.
Wait a second.
The picture room.
Oh, wait.
It was in the other place.
Oh.
Okay.
Awesome.
Uh...
whoa they went bonkers in this room let's read our hint but thank you so much for the pink i'm glad you're having fun in japan i'm always i'm always alone so i'm okay with playing by myself that means i have the right dish and the left dish all to myself i like to play with kokishi dolls a lot i'm extra careful to share them with left hinako and right hinako so it's fair to both of them Inside of you,
there are two Hinako.
It doesn't feel right.
It's like someone's watching me.
Red capsules.
Take it.
Okay.
Gramp.
Oh, heavy.
Heavy.
What the?
Oh, okay.
I knew it.
I knew something like this was going to happen.
Oh, how did I still get hit?
This sucks.
Ouch, ouch.
Ouches.
It's hard to see here.
Sick dodge, thank you.
Until I didn't.
Oh, until I didn't.
Puzzle god.
Yeah, I might be.
okay so we've done all of this area perhaps um so it's just these couple of doors i don't think i can go back i will try though because we have the first crest yay that was her room
first crest done wait oh it should be one out of three that's okay That's fine.
You can be wrong, Gim.
Okay, yeah.
I forgot to grab it!
Oh!
A wooden block with a slanted scale painted on one side.
I wonder what it's for.
Oh, the game saved for me.
Let's go.
Wait.
I could not go in here.
It's because I got caught.
by the mannequin.
Okay, let's resave because I was silly.
And one.
And we go in wait.
In through here.
And around.
Forget it, be- So sorry.
Please excuse my dear aunt Sally.
Oh my gosh.
Oh gosh, she's just sitting there.
Oh my gosh, she's just sitting there.
He took a shadow.
Yeah.
Oh, yeah.
Oh,
don't.
He's got like little horns.
Complicated, huh?
Uh-oh.
Who's around?
What the monster?
Yellowed calendar.
Calendar placed in this room for some reason.
I missed my last birthday yesterday!
There's a happy birthday!
I didn't want to miss another thank you for being such a cute ghost.
Thank you so much!
Happy happy birthday!
I'm sorry I missed it too!
Happy birthday!
Did something like a spawn outside the door?
Most likely.
Okay, hold on.
so just the two rooms left this is this last one has definitely got to be something because it's like a big room um i didn't find literally anything in here and then there's the one wait is this
what's running around oh my gosh
oh i think it's a mannequin
Oh, come on.
Ouch!
Oh, shit.
Eat my crackers.
Okay, cool.
Well, I just lost my sickle.
That sucks.
I'm gonna use my toolbox on this then.
I like the crowbar.
It feels comfortable.
Thank you, half-life.
That feels good.
It feels natural.
Okay.
That's always cool.
I'll pick it up.
Oh, Hinako's diary.
I hate my dad.
I wish he would just die.
I hate my mom, too.
She deserves to die as well.
It's such like a teen...
I understand her situation, but it's...
It sounds like such like a teenager's kind of diary, you know?
If I could just turn into a monster, then I'd take the two of them and crush them to death with my bare hands.
I hate this house, too.
I hate everything.
Everything.
Got some ramen in the closet, though.
Okay.
There's nothing in this room.
Cool.
So what do I do now?
Because...
Sup.
Um...
There's just this door.
I got the crest.
But that's...
Yeah, Hinako has got like Buku bugs.
Do I have this kind of house?
Crazy money.
Crazy.
Oh, I got a calendar also.
That's right.
But...
So I got the picture.
I got the calendar.
And I got the crest.
But I think all of those are two puzzles.
I don't remember an area to...
I don't remember the area to...
What's the word?
Maybe there's a place to hang the calendar in here?
No?
Hmm.
The wall where she said there used to be a calendar.
Wait, is it right here?
Oh, it is!
Okay.
Ah!
Oh, I get it!
Oh my gosh, it's like a weird loop.
So...
Oh.
Whoa!
Whoa.
It's so brightly lit here.
Oh!
Okay.
errand request Hinako I'm sorry but could you drop by Shu's house and buy that stomach medicine for me again also please let his family know that I've been getting better thanks to them traditional medicine truly is better than all those modern drugs and herbal remedies are far gentler on the body tell them that I'll pay my bill at the end of the month mom okay oh who's here
oh the music
Yeah, that's right.
Ouch, ouch, ouch.
Ooh, she hits hard.
Oh, my God.
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
Okay, we're good.
Holy cow.
That was close, I think.
That was pretty bad.
Oof.
Um...
It smells horrible!
What is this?
Oh!
It looks like it reminds me of the grudge so much.
Wow!
That's cool.
Do you think this is gonna grab me?
Guess not.
This is what she'd be putting in the miso soup?
That's sick.
Very cool.
Okay, I was gonna say there should be a safe spot here.
Good soup.
Let's go down this way first.
So many monsters.
More monsters.
No good.
In here.
Because it's like... Oh my gosh.
It's like...
It's hard to explore a little, you know?
Oh!
It's hard to explore.
I feel like you have to kill them or else you really can't like explore so much.
Oh my god, no way.
Oh my gosh!
Stinking Chung is alive!
No, no.
My stamina?
Ah!
Okay.
Oh, gosh!
I'm dumb.
Oh, we got him.
Okay, good.
He ran around so fast!
I didn't know he left the hallway.
That was crazy seeing him!
He spotted me through the door and went around the other way.
What kind of enemy AI is this?
I hate it.
That was terrible.
Oh my gosh.
Another toolkit.
Let's go.
I'm gonna use it on you again.
My precious crowbar, I love you.
Holy count the same as Minecraft.
The Minecraft AI so elite, so smart.
Okay, well we took out those two guys.
Okay.
Was there anything I could get rid of?
I don't think there was anything that I got.
Oh, the Ramin.
Wait!
Oh!
Before I increase my Omamori, I want to see what Omamori I have.
So currently I have Slightly Restores Health after Defeating An Enemy.
Greatly Decreases Focus Charging Time.
There was a...
There was one that I had that I took off.
Increases Max Health.
I could always do that, but then at that point, why wouldn't I just...
I should...
i would just do my health instead of instead max stamina we could always do that but then at the same time also see your eye okay yeah it's just a little dry today sometimes it happens like that slightly restores health after each successful counter decreases enemy line of sight perfect dodges become easier to perform greatly decreases the damage taken while dodging increases stun power when weapon durability is low deals additional damage when using weapons with high durability effective only for weapons with durability really decreases the amount of stamina consumed when sprinting in fights
i think it's a percentile increased based on wait increase on your base health not flat number so it's always useful
there's one where it lowers durability usage for light attack I don't know if you have it yet.
It doesn't seem like it.
I do dodge a lot.
I don't know.
I'm almost feeling because like the feel like the ones that would be most useful are the max stamina.
But then I should just save my...
I don't know.
Horse is comfy for moving around.
I guess that's true.
I will I don't remember if I saved I will just save and we can think on it maybe we'll find some more things as well and we can like oh wait can I already go wait is it is it already looped
whoa that's no good wait oh no I thought that was there was something there was one area that was like there's something supposed to be hanging here
save and roll all the gotcha then reload fragrant letter there are many creatures that discard their shells as they mature i believe that the suffocating feeling you are experiencing is merely a sign of sign that you are growing up a hint that it is time to rid yourself of your shell oh my gosh we're gonna we're gonna we're gonna get rid of our skin you think it's a strange coincidence your name means baby bird i am sure all of this is simply pointing you and the fact that the time for you to spread your wings and fly is drawing near we're molting okay oh whoa uh yes is there something i should be interested in here Oh,
okay.
Okay.
How about the thing that's leaking?
No?
This just looks like a jump scare waiting to happen, no?
Um...
Do she have Yowie?
She is...
She is Miss Yowie.
She actually is the owner of Yowie.
She created Yowie.
Okay.
It wouldn't let me...
Am I dumb?
Maybe?
Is there like a...
Is there like a hint for this or something?
John Yowie?
Next to the bottom box is...
Ah!
Oh!
A block of wax.
A semi-transparent block of wax placed in my diary for some reason.
There seems to be something stuck inside.
Yeah.
I'm super drunk.
Have fun, Rooks!
Be safe!
The music's starting up again.
Okay.
Sorry, I'm always safe scumming in this game.
I, uh...
Do not want to be in a position.
Mostly, I do it because Because that's like, if I die, I really just don't want to redo what I've just done.
You know what I mean?
Alright, who's around?
Who's here?
Show yourself.
In here?
Maybe?
No?
Around the corner?
Wait.
Oh, I think that's a steel bar.
Glam!
give me crowbar or give me death actually don't give me that I want to finish the game oh I think they're behind that door perhaps we'll come back to it
no death No death right now.
Oh, wait a second.
I think I hear you.
Yes, I do.
Oh, there's two of you!
Oh, nasty.
Oh.
Oh, come on!
Asshole!
Okay.
Let me try again.
I've never Come on.
Come on.
Okay, we got one.
Let's kill these guys before I potentially unleash any other creatures upon me.
Girl got a mean swing.
Yeah, she do.
We love her for it.
Oh, come on.
It just sits there.
This is when I wish I had a ranged weapon.
Like guys like this.
Okay, can I please?
Oh, I was too early.
Ah, I messed up.
Yeah.
Oh, nice.
Oh my gosh.
More?
I love the way they kind of look so sassy when they're like walking away they're like with their hair all flowing so many guys all right let's look around a little bit before we do that steel pipe what am i a joke to you another emma wait this is huge okay so there is still something over here Actually,
I'm going to go save because we killed some guys.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
All right.
All right, so I think he's behind whatever creature is here is behind that door.
But we can check this door as well.
What's behind?
Critter door number one.
anything over here anything anything of note anything a bandage okay anything else literally anything okay alright I was constantly saving in this place too I don't blame you it's so big there's so much to explore and if you die there's so much you have to do again in my freaky TARDIS house.
Um.
I don't know how far this goes.
Golly.
I guess let's just see what's behind the door.
Being extra cautious.
Oh.
Oh gosh, we're so close to whatever it is.
Okay, nothing in here.
I don't know.
This feels strange.
Like, I feel like I'm going into a boss room for some reason.
Oh,
this is spooky.
Ouch.
I tried dodging.
These guys hit hard.
Ouch!
Gosh.
I'm just leading around.
out here.
Come.
No?
Oh.
Oh, geez.
Okay.
Alright, now we have plenty of room.
Yeah!
Oh.
Ow, Jellum.
Oh, my gosh.
He gets me first.
Okay.
My weapon.
Alright, time to switch to kitchen knife.
Plenty of room.
room for the monster too yeah but like it's hard I don't want to hit the walls it's like so annoying that's why I'd rather just lead them to the lead them to an area take two
oh okay see I feel like I was right that this leads to to some sort of, okay, I'm gonna come back here last.
I wanna say you inspired me to pass out candy this year so I pretend to be dead in the truck of my car holding a cauldron of candy.
All the kids said, trick or veto?
Because you're always a treat.
What are you talking about?
Can't tell if you're serious or not.
Not about the trick or veto, but you giving out candy.
Oh, wait.
Sounds fun, though.
I think I need to make a decision.
Okay, what I'm going to do...
I just saved.
Oh, it's 700!
I thought it was 500.
Okay, I think I just need to increase my abilities.
I think maybe I will do the Omamori slot, and then I will save up for health.
Potentially.
What I could do is the Omamori slot, I could do increased stamina.
I really was in my trunk.
My booty hurts.
Sounds fun.
Always bring the best form of entertainment.
You always make me smile.
We don't...
Oh, so good.
Thank you.
Okay, Omamori.
And we save for health.
And let's add an...
Let's do...
Maybe like...
The stamina one.
Especially if we're aiming to increase our health next.
So...
I'm going to save this room because it looks fancy and special and we're gonna go take care of whatever the hecky is going on in here.
I think this door probably opens, just kidding.
Of course it doesn't.
All right.
I don't want to turn my back on this area either, but...
Hello!
Do you see me?
Oh, no you don't?
Yes, you do.
No, you don't.
Okay.
Suggest you?
Took care of her.
Give me some capsules.
Um, cool.
That was pretty hardcore.
Snake would be proud?
You think so?
You really think so?
Oh, this is the room I didn't go in before.
I sure hope I didn't, like, Furoshiki.
Increases inventory capacity!
I was going to say, I hope I didn't, like, miss something out that was going to soft lock me or something.
But I remember we have to go back there anyway, because the pictures and stuff.
Ancient wisdom passed down by our ancestors.
Used to wrap things up and carry them around.
Good thing I always prefer function over fashion.
Yeah!
Good find.
I thought that was a gnome.
I don't know why.
And a toolkit!
Wait, this room is awesome!
And a propane tube!
A pipeline that can be connected to a stove.
Looks old but works fine.
Okay.
What are we using the tube for?
What's this bird pattern?
I don't know.
And then there, I think there was one other door over here.
Oh, um, uh, uh, whoa!
Oh.
Wow!
Whoa!
Oh, he's looking at me.
Ew!
I should leave right away.
Hmm.
Okay, y'all have to tell me twice.
That might have been one of the cooler things we've seen in this game.
That was really neat.
Okay.
Also, I'm gonna use the toolkit once again.
This thing is not very durable, but I like it so much.
uh oh whoops i'm willing to you know keep it maintained until i find a new one or something was i think it was a kokashi doll wasn't it or am i wrong all right let's try this room now oh it's stuck oh wait no wait just just move it oh wait no way i i waited to go back to the
Uh...
No way.
I thought this was like a big deal.
Oh, it won't even let me try again.
Just give up.
Bozo.
Okay.
It's a lore vase.
Okay, one other thing I want to try with this guy real quick.
It looks like I could maybe stab him in the eyeball.
I'm gonna try.
So maybe I just go through that other door.
But before then, I want to try this.
Oh.
Okay.
So creepy.
So cool.
Okay, okay, okay.
Creepy ambience.
Let's go through this door now.
It'll let me, I imagine, because it's on.
Does this take me to the beginning?
No?
Uh...
Wait, yes?
Yes, it does.
Oh, okay.
Oh, I killed you guys!
I killed you!
I killed everything in here.
You can't come back.
It's unfair.
Okay.
If only we had our Yeti powers.
Seriously.
So I'm guessing... Oh.
I'm guessing the scale goes in here and then the fox goes on one side and the sword goes on the other whenever we get those.
What else do I hear?
Oh my gosh.
Where did you come from?
Ouch.
Oh, no.
I dodge and you still leaped at me.
Oh, what are you doing?
What happens when you does that?
Oh, it goes like cycle mode.
Oh.
Ah!
Yeah!
He doesn't go psycho mode, he goes freak mode.
It looks like a fire is happening.
Oh, I think I was right.
Wait.
Oh!
Whoa.
Oh.
No, the opposite of fire.
Water.
Whoa!
Crazy visual!
It's kind of funny, just like...
Here we go.
White bird and fox plate.
A wooden block with a white bird painted on one side and a fox on the other.
Wonder...
What was that?
Gonna run for it?
In fact, I'm going to save right here instead.
Okay, we got two crests.
No, thank you.
Let's put the other crest here.
Wait, let me read this again.
Foxes.
The sun rose behind the foxes back and set behind the swords.
So does it...
east hot dog hot dog happy slashing okay share my day my car broke down six miles from US Idol Festival now I can't make it to the concert or meet a greet how will I ever recover wait a lottery what lottery wait what I'm
so sorry wait hold on I have to read this again.
The sun rises behind the fox's back.
So maybe this one.
And then, what is this?
Okay.
So we found two of the three crests.
We did the picture frames.
What?
Oh, wait.
What is this?
to.
There's another one?
Wait.
Oh, because this is to shoe.
This is to shoe.
Ah, okay.
Maybe we get the one to shoe in here, I imagine.
But what other puzzle was there?
Seems like some doors are unchecked.
Oh, you're right.
You're right, you're right.
Oh, geez.
Okay, I just saved, though, so it should be okay.
We'll go down this way.
But I don't think...
If we just got one in here, I don't imagine there's another one.
You know?
Oh.
Oh, okay.
Inazushi, let's go.
I will sell that.
For big bucks.
I think I just didn't...
Oh, okay.
Yeah, we'll check my notes in a second.
I think it was that in fact that I just didn't check them before.
I think I went through the door and I forgot to check my
notes.
Wait, my notes.
Okay, I did the scales, obviously.
I did the photos.
Wait, there was not another puzzle, was there?
Yes.
Maybe it goes to the room in here this time.
I definitely remember not going in here before because I was spooked.
Do you need a propane tube?
It does!
Oh my gosh!
I'm making soup?
Oh!
Fletching key!
Ah!
The door with the bird on it!
A key with a bird pattern on the back obtained from the melted piece of wax.
Oh my god!
Oh my gosh.
Also, oh my god.
Ouch!
You bitch!
Please!
Ow!
Gosh, no!
Oh my god, I might die here.
No!
Oh!
Oh, this is bad.
Run, run, run, run, run, run, run!
Time to leave, time to leave.
Time to leave while I heal.
And I'm just gonna go.
I'm going.
I'm leaving.
We're going to the next room.
We're going.
We're leaving.
I'm leaving?
Okay.
Holy cow.
We need to go to the next one again.
Ah, shoot.
Ouch.
Stop it.
Okay, we got her.
Thanks for keeping me company on a two-hour drive home.
Your webinars really keep me sane in traffic.
Glad you like my webinars.
We're just gonna run for it.
Wait, have I...
I didn't try opening this?
Could I before?
Oh my gosh.
I'm saving literally over everything just in this one house.
Because I'm afraid of like kind of soft locking myself with...
okay.
Okay, I hear monster.
I'm afraid because I'm running out of weapons so quickly, you know what I mean?
I guess there are a bunch of steel bars or...
Oh, nasty, please!
Ouch, ouch, ouch, ouch, ouch.
Wait, oh gosh.
I'm just gonna run.
I know there will probably be other stuff down here.
Probably right around this corner.
Really?
Nothing?
Lucky.
Don't say that, please.
Oh.
Hinako!
that's all.
Oh, what's that?
No, my god.
I know.
It's your dad's grotesque, and that's why.
Oh?
My god.
Oh, what?
In order for me to crack into all the money and all she ers, all the money saved is your father's sorry.
My god.
My thaw!
Mom and my eyme even came out of him for being otherwise.
No.
Wow.
What?
No.
Whoa.
What?
Oh!
Oh, I'm sorry, but, oh, your son's got you come to come here.
Eh?
That's it!
Like a hoi.
What?
He threw
a knife at her.
Insane.
Okay.
Okie dokie.
There's nothing else in here.
Alright.
we'll have our knife on hand blackbird and sword plate a wooden block with a blackbird painted on one side and a katana on the other wonder what it's for alright enter the room
okay so we leave we go back okay time to run yeah time to run baby
oh just saved
why my
journal updated why oh mom
we'll read this real quick but then i saw that mannequin a woman's happiness begins with marriage she told me that every opportunity she got am i supposed to believe that she's actually happy with the life she has now in this house today my dad threw a knife it got stuck the tatami mat.
There are chips and dings all over the house.
Every last one is from when he threw something.
Is that what happiness is to my mother seeing her house in such a sorry state and full of scars?
I've heard that dad used to be a fisherman when he was younger and would go on long fishing trips way out at sea.
He managed to save up enough money doing that to open up a restaurant, a place where he could put his skills with a knife to use.
It didn't work out though not only did he lose all his savings he took on new debt too now he spends his days drinking his life away in the sleepy little town that's a long way from sea he never even tries to cook anything anymore it's only when he complains about mom's food that he pretends to be some kind of important chef is
this new i used to think it was just my dad who was like this but after listening to all the married women around here complain every man seems just as bad while their husbands are just as short-tempered just as violent just as useless and do just as little to help out their wives i don't remember if i read this or not after learning this every grumpy old man in town i see reminds me of him when i think that i was born and raised just to support these horrible tyrants i lose all hope if everything works out they're going to give my father a lot of money i'm sure he's desperate to use it to pay back his debts is selling me to pay back his debts?
Huh?
Oh, my god.
Are you the one that was getting me earlier?
Get up!
Die, monster!
Die!
Okay.
We got her.
Nice.
Okay.
Alright, and I think there's down that hallway.
Alright, alright.
Alright.
Okay.
Yeah.
That thing.
Alright.
So I think probably...
Is this not it?
Am I wrong?
Check the clues again.
Yeah.
The sword and the fox fought battling upon a set of scales.
Wait, the scales are gone!
Okay, wait.
Maybe it's like this.
Aha!
I'm gonna look around a bit.
Red capsules.
Okay.
Pine tree emblem.
Oh!
What's she doing?
Why she didn't want to talk to him?
Hello?
What's up?
Oh, I can leave?
Wait, will you help me?
Oh, you're so cute.
First of all, why are you wearing that stupid outfit?
I don't know.
I don't know what I'm thinking.
What do you mean?
What are you talking about?
I'm probably...
You're not me.
I'm not you.
I'm not.
It's true, duh.
If I was Hinako, then who are you?
Oh, Hinako is the same.
But...
My heart is...
Hmm?
Shimizu Hinako is not...
What are you saying?
What are you talking about?
Oh.
It's true, duh.
Oh!
My body is...
I want to talk to you...
...shimizu Hinako to be really honest with you.
Wow.
We're...
...we're all right.
...and we're all right.
You have this stupid body, your heart.
If you have this stupid body, your heart.
Oh, come on, come on, come on.
Wait, wait, wait, no, no, no.
It's not only you, not only.
I'll kill you.
My father and my mother will kill me.
This house, this city will be killed.
I'll kill you.
Rinko and Saku-ko will kill me.
And of course...
Shu?
You know, your very important partner, too.
Shu, where?
Where are you?
Where are you going to be?
Hey.
Shu is so much important.
I love her voice actress.
She's so good.
Her actress is doing a playthrough too.
Wait, that's so awesome.
So good.
Don't say that.
Okay, we gotta go through here.
I think I'm just gonna run past...
Damn!
So much we're running past!
Ouch!
Oh my god, wait, I don't want to die.
Wait, I don't want to die.
I don't want to die!
Okay.
Yeah.
Well, that sucks.
Um, let's see.
Well, it doesn't really matter.
It just saves anyway.
Okay.
Can you guys, like, fight each other?
Why can't there be, like, monster...
Why can't the monsters fight each other, you know?
Just throw up yourself to death.
Oh, gosh.
I just was gonna...
run past oh
my gosh oh my gosh I don't want to die I hate these things so stinking much but please please please please did it die oh my gosh I lived somehow I lived holy cow so unfair it's terrible Oh my gosh.
I hate those things so much.
Oh, one up.
She lives.
Somehow.
Open the door to the Rube Shoe's voice came from.
Okay.
Now can I run past?
Now do you think it's okay?
Probably.
There we go.
Bye.
Oh, don't say that.
Wait, where are you?
I thought you were gonna be right behind.
Oh, jeez.
Wait, though.
Ah, Seiko!
We'll take that.
Whoa.
Seiko.
Okay, we made it.
Maybe...
Oh.
Hold on.
Oh, wow.
There's like...
Whoa.
Uh, something big's coming up, huh?
Not good.
Just so close to...
Even that though, 60 wouldn't give me enough to offer it for health.
That's okay.
Wait.
Capsules.
This doesn't seem very good.
Oh, oh, okay.
Oh, okay.
You two don't look.
Oh!
Oh, she's like all burnt up.
Yeah, we did, we did that.
Yeah.
Oh yeah, what's with the buckets?
Oh my gosh, it's the knife.
My head's blocking it, but...
Oh.
Why is his mouth like that?
This is...
This isn't cannibalism, right?
Yeah, he's super uncanny.
It's so creepy.
Am I going to have to fight my dad?
Oh, no.
Oh,
gosh.
Okay.
Oh, no.
Shut up.
thing with the blade at the beginning.
I like how she has the steel pipe.
I guess that's like the default, like the main weapon.
Oh, and mom too!
Oh my gosh, she throws stuff at you.
Okay.
Wow!
Oh my gosh!
This seems kind of brutal.
I'm not gonna lie.
Oh gosh!
Oh
my god, rude!
They team up!
Oh my gosh!
Oh gosh!
Oh no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no!
No, no, no, no, no!
Oh my god, please!
Oh my god, mom!
Okay,
we're dead, we're dead.
She like throws you to him!
Oh, we're so dead.
Ouch, ouch.
I didn't realize she had one more attack.
Ah!
Run away, run away.
Run away.
Oh, you are so rude.
I don't know.
I feel like I need to focus on the mom first.
Oh!
Please, please.
Oh, that was so close.
That was so close.
I have no stamina.
Oh, I should have dodged.
I tried to dodge, but that's okay.
I was able to heal anyway.
Come here.
Come here, bitch.
Oh!
dodge please let me dodge yeah oh okay yeah oh
you still going okay i'm gonna lose all my weapons oh i'll tell tell tell i just couldn't dodge i couldn't
uh oh my gosh no no Dutch!
Okay.
Oh, dang.
If I... Oh, I need more stamina.
Imagine if I didn't have like the stamina thing.
Oh, ouch, ouch, ouch.
I mean, just keep going.
Dutch!
I need you to die before I lose all my weapons please Oh my gosh please Oh gosh Oh my
god All I have is one thing Mom dropped the knife Wait where she did Oh thank you Oh my gosh
Let's also...
He's not dead?
So lame!
Bye!
I guess.
He's just dropping all his innards.
Ooh, look.
too seriously I just be I think he had way more on his body than that he just digested the rest I guess first try go give her thank you
oh where are you going
back to Yeti Arm?
I'm sorry, what is there?
Parting on good terms.
Good terms?
No, I'm here to burn bridges.
Is what the...
Achievement, which...
I forgot we have the mask, too.
We're like crazy now.
In the wrecky suit.
Yeah, Yeti may cry.
Oh,
come on, Ninako.
I think it just would have been better if they made the...
The hair less stringy.
Like...
It's like so stringy and thin like it looks gross and not like a spooky way.
Oh,
yeah.
Angel hair.
Yeah, it's like, yeah.
It just makes me laugh.
Drink up.
You're gonna make me have to pee.
Right some water.
Oh.
Oh gosh, her mouth though.
She doesn't look good.
She actually looks quite bad.
I think she's allergic to that stuff.
Also known as sake.
Yeah.
This is just what women look like without makeup.
You're so right.
What's this?
Ooh.
Oh, oh.
Again?
You're not going to leave me this time, are you?
Funny ears fit more now.
Welcome back to Vembo Ship.
Thank you so much.
Oh, there he goes.
Typical.
This guy.
Broach.
This very old and precious broach seems to have a reassuring power.
Explore.
Are things not going to attack me now because they're like, oh, she belongs to that guy.
Varno, thank you so much for the tiny gift.
Thank you.
I don't remember how to activate that.
I think it was like L3 or something or whatever it was.
There's not stuff around here, is there?
be exploring.
I just realized.
He didn't leave any trinkets.
Oh, wait.
Let's save for sure, since I just beat a boss.
I just beat... I just beat Dad.
So...
Let's save.
Happy November, Mindo.
Happy November!
Thank you so much!
Whoa!
Kamik, thank you!
Welcome back, and thank you for the 50 gifts, and holy moly.
Thank you.
Investigate the area
I would say that maybe things don't bother us anymore because You know because we have the brooch but I guess This is a silent hill game They wouldn't make it that easy Prove your intent with the crests 3 Show what lies deep within your heart Let the line of foxes guide you Offer the crests and lay bare your soul
more crests more crests awesome love it a black bird wishes to take the white bird the white bird wishes to resist the foe oh sorry whips should wouldn't contain themselves if they saw kitsune minto with her fluffy tails touch fluffy tails The white bird wishes to resist.
The fox brings along his followers in triumph.
He notices not the two birds in conflict.
So it's not my problem.
I'm not going to talk to these stupid birds.
Okay.
This...
This looks pretty...
bad i don't think we don't want to go close to them if they're covered in blood on the bottom
okay oasis oh yeah sources family physicians log february 13th dawn mr hidetoshi and his wife have passed away one after the other at time of death the skin all over their bodies was covered in sores and had begun
Slout Slout Slout Slout Slout What do you mean daddy issues weren't the bottom bars?
Right!
Sloughing Sloughing off The smell was indescribably awful I could not bear to take a closer look The head of the...
The head of the house did not give permission to perform autopsies on the bodies There will be no funeral sent to be cremated immediately.
February 14th, midnight.
The eldest son has passed away.
Again, there will be no funeral, and the body will be sent away for cremation.
The eldest and second-born daughters are also experiencing symptoms that are worsening by the hour.
I believe they will be in critical condition by tomorrow, at the latest.
That's a hard word.
Oh, that's right.
Do these do anything?
Oh, oh, whoa, aww, little babies.
Is there anything up here?
Anything in your mouth?
Let go, let go, spit it out.
You got anything in your mouth?
Wait, what?
Did it just make a noise at me?
Spit it out, spit it out.
middle.
What do you mean?
Oh, he dropped that.
Oh, he did spit it out.
Okay.
It won't let me observe any of the other ones.
Hmm.
There was something on the first box?
There was?
Oh!
Ooh.
Ornate scroll.
Purify once and for all.
Leave the of your world behind.
Well, thank you, guys.
I definitely did not see that at all.
Thank you, thank you.
Oh, sorry.
I keep checking the map.
I think it's...
What?
Ah.
Oh.
I have the brooch!
Leave me alone!
Leave me alone, foul beast.
Umamori!
Slyly restores current max sanity after defeating enemies.
Oh?
Okay.
I was thinking of stamina.
Doggo!
I guess this would be good for Yeti armor!
Jeez!
You two!
Two of them!
Wait, oh shoot.
Wait.
Oh my gosh.
I'm stupid.
My stamina.
When did you guys get so strong?
Ugh.
Gimme, gimme, gimme.
When did they get so strong?
Ugh.
Things just crying over there by itself.
What's this?
Yo-Kan!
Hmm.
Anything else?
Whoa!
These environments are so cool, though.
It's one thing this game really does right.
It's just...
A really cool environment.
The setting is so awesome.
What's this?
Oh, Aburagi.
There was a fox shrine I went to Once I had like all the foxes everywhere You know
Not even just spooky But just like visually Interesting I guess is the best way I would put it Hold on, I'm gonna take a cough drop My voice is A little dead after well i practiced singing yesterday and then i sang today and then did i get this already yeah and then meet and greet and now talking did i get some inari zushi at the inari shrine unfortunately no yeah yeah oh oh gosh you got me first
oh my god i hear it breaking I'm kind of insane.
I just tried to crawl away from me.
I just...
I tried to crawl away.
I was like, wait, wait, wait, please.
I just went Yeti mode on it.
Ducky, thanks for the captain!
Do they fear me now?
Because I...
Have the brooch.
Oh, uh...
How do I do the Yeti Vision?
Wait, ah.
Hold on, I need to... Oh, not map.
Sorry.
I need to go to my tutorials.
Yeti Vision.
L2?
Ah, thank you.
Thank you, thank you.
though.
What was in here?
Black Sparrow Crest.
Ah, a badge with something carved.
Onto it looks like a black sparrow.
Oh look, it shows you like that it's in there.
That's kind of fun.
Codenya, thank you for the gifted!
Housemaids note.
Surely after I became their maid, there was of an arranged marriage for the young heir to a noble woman.
This led to their heir unceremoniously ending all his scandalous relationships with women, including one with a young housemaid named Sachi Sachi came from a family of poor farmers, but her beauty shone brighter than the sun.
I'm so sorry.
Something that had caught the young heir's eye.
By the time his marriage was being arranged, she already had a life-growing inside of her, and the two had made vows to run away and start a new life together.
Scandalous!
And yet the young heir cruelly and wantonly cast her aside.
Likely, he simply did not want his prospective marriage to be ruined.
So the Tsunekis kicked Satie out and drove her to some far-off place where they could forget her existence, despite the peace of the family she carried with her.
People say that she was fighting back tears so hard that blood began to trickle from her eyes.
Oh my gosh.
So metal.
Cool.
Saving, thank you.
Ah, okay.
Can I put it anywhere or?
Um.
Oh.
Uh.
Okay.
Hmm.
This clue, right?
Prove your intent with the crest three.
Show what lies deep within your heart.
Let the line of foxes guide you.
Offer the crest and lay bare your soul.
Sorry, I didn't read that one out loud.
Okay.
Um...
Do I just go...
I think I went this way.
Is it... Okay, I can...
Follow the line of foxes.
So maybe I can only put it in ones that are facing forward.
So it'll be one...
There's so many holes though!
Huh?
Wait.
There's so many.
Like this guy's facing behind, you know.
This guy's facing behind.
And this guy's facing behind.
check the other doors
oh my gosh since I woke up I've been so fleming like my throat doesn't hurt but I just like all day I've been having to be like you know I don't know why so much ectoplasm
the Tineki oh housemaids note the Tinekis are the most notable family in this area and are known for their wealth for generations each head of the family has possessed a talent for business an acumen they have utilized during times of social unrest to amass a large fortune you've been getting that so bad yeah it sucks too much boogers it probably is seasonal changes it's so cold you guys it's so stinking cold recently it's hard to get it was almost so hard to get out of morning i was like i'm gonna freeze i'm gonna be gonna become a acto sickle however given that a great many suffered while they grew rich their actions have often drawn envious eyes healthy throat through healthy throat beave thank you when i first entered into service with the tzuneckis my grandmother shared some of the many rumors that swirl around the family each time the world falls to pieces the tzuneckis treasury only grows larger the But Seneckis are happily waiting for misfortunes to strike so they can line
their pockets.
Yikes.
Great bunch.
Nasty.
Oh, there we go.
Divine water.
Gulp, gulp, gulp.
Which way do I go?
Oh, well.
Commit.
Strict mother's letter.
Oh, yeah!
Good morning, my handsome boy.
Your real last name is Tsuneki.
It is told that those of the Tsuneki lineage are destined to bring good fortune when the world is in disorder.
In fact, that is how your father earned succession to the Tsuneki lineage.
And you who have inherited your father's noble blood are sure to be next in line.
Wait, is this the lady that got cast aside?
To make your name, I took one character from your father's name and one from mine.
That way, when anyone from the Toneki family hears your name, they will immediately know you are our child.
Oh, thank you.
They got me anything for me.
Thank you.
There was one here.
And one in the middle.
Hey, you got something in your mouth?
Spit it out.
Wait, what door did I come in from?
This is why I wish I could have access to the map.
Wait, I'm, like, actually lost.
Where did I come in from?
Over there?
I think there, because the letter was here.
Oh my gosh, please.
I feel like I'm going to get lost in here.
Hi, lost.
I'm Wisp.
Wisp!
Oh, oh, oh, what is that?
It sounds big.
Oh, oh.
There's two of them.
Whoa, whoa.
What is going on in here?
Torture room?
Maybe.
Yeah.
Oh my god.
It's you.
Touch.
Ah!
There's two of them!
Oh my gosh.
I thought you guys were supposed to be scared of me.
Dodge.
Oh gosh.
Ouch.
Dodge.
Ah!
Ouch.
Wait.
I can't move.
I'm stuck.
this sucks dodge oh my god one's running at me one is running at me they're both running at me oh I got them somehow holy moly oh geez oh camera please I was just anything please that was crazy got that strong hand Thank goodness, right?
Nasty.
Nasty fellas.
I feel like I shouldn't have come in here.
I feel like maybe I made a mistake on which door I went through.
Is there anything in here?
So the way this section works is whenever you pick the wrong door, you get sent here again and have to fight.
Oh, I see.
Thank you.
It's just a trap room.
Horrible.
Wait.
How am I supposed to know which door is correct?
Which one is correct?
Okay.
This blood splatter is wrong.
Let the fox guide you.
So he is very distinctly staring at the door.
The other guys...
Yeah, I think it's this one.
The other guys are kind of like looking...
Well, this guy's also...
Well, maybe he's looking at this blood.
I don't know.
I'll try.
Use concentration?
Oh, wait, that's wrong thing.
Wait, what was it?
No?
Or is it?
One of the foxes has something stabbed in it.
Wait, did I not get that?
Oh, wait, I think I get it.
Oh, okay, wait.
No.
Because it turned before.
And like its eyes shone.
But nothing had it stabbed this time.
Try staring at the floor.
Whoa!
This one too!
Oh my god.
You got anything?
Nothing up your butt?
Oh wait, I see it, I see it.
That.
Grab it.
Oh wait.
Examine, grab it.
I would have never figured that out.
Perish once and for all, Shimizu Hinako shall disappear today.
Oh, okay.
So it's this way then, because he's...
Uh-huh.
Oh.
Oh, geez.
Oh, cheese.
I don't know
where it last picked up.
Oh, okay, right here.
Can I, like, leave?
What if I just ignore him?
Oh, shoot.
Okay, I don't like that.
I don't like you guys either.
What the?
You can't dodge my attack?
Wait, is he in here?
Oh, yes he is.
Wait, I need her.
No.
Let me have her, please.
Ah!
Where did you come from?
No!
Please.
Dodge.
There's something.
She's back alive already!
Evil.
Oh, this is so evil.
Wait, this is really evil.
Oh my god.
Oh my god, this sucks.
Wait, guys, this sucks.
Oh, this sucks.
I need you.
Oh my god, I need to soul siphon you, but I can't!
You're just gonna wake up again!
No, I'm ready!
Wait, I'm trying to...
Wait, how do I pull my devil trigger?
Um, hold on.
I thought it was L3, but it's not working.
Oh, it's both sticks!
Yeah!
You done?
Okay.
Oh.
What about...
Oh, okay.
That's right.
When I kill them, when I'm Devil Trigger, they...
they disappear already.
They disappear forever.
Yay!
Okay, anything else around here?
Holy moly.
Yeah, auto siphons.
Yeah, yeah.
I hear her in there.
Maybe I'm just gonna take her out so that we can...
Oh, whoops.
So that we can get more soul siphon.
Yeah, yeah.
Take her out to dinner?
She wishes.
She wishes she could even get a stroke of this Yeti arm.
Amito getting cocky?
No, not at all.
I just died.
Why would I be getting cocky?
I just, I literally just died in this room before.
Sure, when I have a Yeti trigger, it makes me feel a little better, but...
Cocky?
Like, I think what it is about the arm is it just reminds me so much of a dog I used to have.
And my mom would be like, oh, he's not ugly.
His hair is just wiry.
I'm such an ugly dog.
Oh, white sparrow crest.
the light sparrow.
What kind of dog did you have?
I don't remember.
It was like, it was my mom's dog.
She was like so into this dog.
But I think, how?
Lopsa opsa something?
I don't know.
I don't remember.
It was ugly and it had an underbite and it like would go up to you and be like, but it wasn't a pug.
It just did that.
I don't know what it was
ugly my dad would always be like why did you bring that thing home it just felt so bad for him and then my grandma would feed him food that he couldn't eat and so we would just like fart all the time like he had he was very sweet he just had no redeeming qualities like you know like he just had a lot of things against him yeah i was pretty cursed i think uh i got let's just give the divine water uh the abra again oh here we go we have a lot of stuff actually that i can let's do the kazu
and um i will pray for oh wow i already did all the omamori slots that's awesome I think I'll still do more health.
Even though I've been running out of stamina so quickly lately.
Very sweet, but not very good looking.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
You want it for the final boss.
Wait, want what?
The health?
Yeah, enemies are doing beefy damage.
That's true.
I think I'll go with...
You now have more holes.
We could always get more.
Well, I don't have an Emma.
We could!
Hold on.
Save.
We're gonna save.
And we're gonna draw.
Omamori Sakura enhances the effects of health restoring items and...
Oh wait, health restoring items and omamoris.
What do I...
Do I have any health Omamori.
Sorry, it's so funny.
Slightly restores health after defeating an enemy.
Greatly decreases focus charging.
Max stamina.
So yeah, I do.
Crow plus Sakura.
you hoard health items because you never use i use oh oh i i thought you meant like you wouldn't use them oh that's fair that's fair you would just keep collecting them and never have to use them but i feel like in the final boss battle you would probably have to use them because i mean like unless he summons other things you know which he probably will whatever the boss is
I'll think about it I'll still keep it though I think that was pretty good Okay Which one have I not gone into
Ew More emblems Did I go through this door?
Yes So I go through this door Let me just get them first, and then I'll...
Let me just get them first, and then I will...
Oh my goodness, there's so many!
Then I'll decide where to put them, I'll figure it out.
Amblums, emblems!
We need more emblems!
Oh, hello?
Goodbye, motor, thank you.
In deed.
You?
Oh, we found it.
That was fast.
Oh, I keep forgetting I have to do the examine.
Ornate scroll, sacrifice once and for all, body and soul, made pure by rebirth.
Awful, awful.
Offer all that is yours.
That door.
Got it.
Thank you.
Hold on.
I must acquire everything else that the fox offered to me.
You all are stingy.
What is this?
Strict mother's letter.
Good morning, handsome boy.
I have good news.
Indeed, good news to a Tsuneki is always...
accompanied by the news of someone else's death your father and that woman he kept as a pet have both gotten sick and died and now your grandfather the head of the house has invited you to the tzineki residence to make you successor it is a pity that i couldn't reacquaint you with your father but at least i was able to make you successor to the tzineki lineage damn no no no no facts wait i gotta check these more Is that really it?
There's no...
Oh, wait.
You're not easy.
Oh.
Do you have anything?
What did I waste my mind powers on you for?
Wait, what's going on here?
Whoa.
That's cool.
Good morning, handsome, Minto.
Oh!
I'm handsome!
This one.
No!
Yes?
Oh, yes.
I thought I was back.
Ah!
Um, oh, geez.
Oh, geez.
Ah, I owe each other.
Oh, my God.
Yeah, let's go.
Oh, God.
There's a big guy!
Oh my gosh!
I'm getting my ass!
My ass handed to me!
Not my ass!
Oh my ass!
Oh my gosh!
Moli!
This is insanity!
Wait, did I...
Oh my gosh, no please!
I wanted to see if there was a siphon, yes.
You asshole, please!
Okay.
Oh my gosh.
Oh my god, I'm gonna freaking make lose it.
Okay.
Soul Siphon, Soul Siphon.
Please.
I just need the Soul Siphon you please!
Okay.
So he doesn't come back.
Oh wait.
Yeah!
Oh, it's okay.
It's okay.
It doesn't hurt me.
I don't care.
I'm in beast mode.
Yeah.
Take that.
Oh my gosh.
I can't even read what it says.
Not that, you know, I might not be able to read it because, you know, kanji, but I try.
Oh, it's so scary!
Oh, forsaken!
Okay.
All right, let's get out of this crazy room.
Oh, where have you been?
Oh, Juko!
my sister way to pull your yedi trigger thank you i only know kanji for one two and three
yeah does she mean
Oh, you gave us like two seconds, my goodness.
No.
Why does Junko not have a fox mask?
So interesting.
Big Mac, thank you so much for the five guesses.
Married to the Tengu family?
No, I don't think it's a Tengu.
Tengu has like a long nose.
Married to another family.
It is a Tengu!
It looks so strange though.
Leave the room.
Okay.
Hmm,
hmm, hmm, hmm, hmm, hmm.
You thought crow.
I thought so, too.
I thought it looked like a kind of crow-like.
I just want to see the paintings.
This one.
It's cool.
Whoa.
okay so okay i don't know why i thought it said solve the marital status i was like huh because she's married okay this one i'm actually a bit stumped on black bird wishes to take the white bird the white bird wishes to resist.
The fox brings along his followers in triumph.
He notices not the two birds in conflict.
So the white bird is resisting.
The black bird wants to go.
It's a lot of holes.
That's why it's kind of difficult.
Take a good look at all the fox guys.
Some of them are looking it seems like that this one looks like he's looking at his lamp so I feel like it's not that because he's he doesn't need to notice right alright but I overthinking it I can't tell
you have three coins and three foxes facing the other way but no He's supposed to be leading them, right?
This feels like maybe the fox.
More emblems.
And then maybe the one turned away.
See, like, this guy here is looking at the lamp.
This guy's looking away.
Maybe this is the white bird.
This is the black bird.
Basically the thing about conflict is what screwed me up because honestly none of them looked like they were fighting me but I guess they were.
Oh, they are?
Huh?
Wait, hmm?
They are?
They're fighting?
The girls are fighting?
Two of them are fighting?
They are?
Um, this guy looks angry.
They all look angry.
This guy's smiling.
He's the only one that is, like, chip, chip, chippery.
Maybe he is the one that has the fox crest, then.
He's happy.
The girls are fighting.
This guy looks angry here.
Who's angry?
Can I not read social cues?
Can I...
Read it again?
The fox bringing along his followers in triumph.
You notice it's not the two bird in conflict.
New fear unlocked.
Like, this guy's just like chill.
He's just like, Yahoo!
I think he's happy.
He doesn't notice, right?
I don't know.
Unless he's supposed to be turned away from the two that are fighting.
Oh.
Who's... This guy looks angry too.
Are you fighting?
The two near the top look like they're fighting.
These two?
Oh wait, maybe actually...
Maybe like this.
Yeah, other way.
Maybe then...
I was right the first time?
Just this dude being all happy.
Oh!
Yippee yippee yippee!
Those guys were fighting.
Thank you guys for the hints.
Yahoo!
Oh.
Yes?
It's the only conflict in the...
Main thing, I guess that's true.
What is it?
Is that a ring?
Oh my gosh!
Are we making it official?
You guys are posting spoilers.
Uh, try not to.
Uh, but...
I'm also not looking so much.
Oh my god.
Yeah.
Wait!
I didn't make that sound!
Wait, that wasn't like a soundboard I- I-
Why did this the divine boom happen?
Why did that took me out entirely?
What just happened?
Oh my god, there's shoes.
Reduced to Adams.
Oh my gosh.
Uh-oh.
Oh, geez.
Oh my god.
Can't we get a break?
Yeah, go ape shit!
Said chase after the monster, but I don't know which...
Oh!
Oh, geez.
Oh my god.
This guy is so fast!
Uh-oh, where am I?
I'm about to lose my weapon.
Can I like run past?
No, I can't.
Oh my gosh.
Of course not.
Oh, there's a baseball bat!
Ah, my weapon!
Oh geez.
My axe is also almost dead.
Wait, I can't.
I can't.
Oh my gosh, please, let me out.
Is it still wanting me to chase?
I don't like it.
Oh, here.
Double hit.
Why are they phasing into each other?
Oh, I'm...
Oh, because of the... Oh my gosh, it sucks.
Oh, come on!
Yeah!
I'm just gonna take the other baseball bat.
Is there anything around here?
Red capsules.
Yeah, go Ape Shit!
Shimizu!
Hinako!
Oh, it just saved, but...
I'll pray.
Do I have anything to enshrine?
Oh, I do have Inari-zushi.
Um, I don't think we need to offer it right now, though.
Scarlet, thank you so much!
Welcome back!
There's an axe?
Wait, there was?
Oh, yes!
Thank you.
I don't even have enough for Gacha.
Oh!
Jesus!
Ah, you nasty!
Yeah!
Take that!
What's this?
Oh, thank you.
I will offer this now, actually.
I like how this part has, like, the music.
That makes it seem like it's...
You're supposed to be, like...
You're fast pace.
But I'm, like, going at my own.
My own little pace.
Chase the fog monster.
Where'd it go?
Oh gosh, everything's red.
Everything's red.
What
does that sound?
Ah!
Oh, dang.
Whoa.
Home run, baby.
Another baseball bat.
They just keep getting me bats.
And a toolkit.
If only I had all my other weapons.
I think I like...
Wait, uh...
Yeah, I like broke everything.
That's okay.
Kitchen knife is best weapon.
I don't have a kitchen knife.
What do you want me to do?
Oh, use the weapon you don't have.
Okay.
Oh, I did get a sickle, though.
Let's go.
Oh.
I would love to get close to you and do this.
I'm about to lose all my sanity, though.
though.
And a steel pipe.
We'll take that over the baseball bat.
Actually, I don't know which one's better, but whatever.
I think they were similar.
I kind of liked using the bat, though.
It made me feel powerful.
Hello?
Oh, you again.
They love throwing this lady at you.
It's kind of horrible.
Oh my gosh.
Ouch.
Ouch, ouch!
Oh, Jesus, please!
Ah!
Yep, yep!
Ah, I tried to dodge, but I got stuck on something.
I got stuck on the environment.
Oh, oh.
Okay.
Lady, please!
Oh, no!
Please!
I'm trying to focus on not the blob of shit, please.
Oh my gosh.
Ouch!
Please!
This is too much.
This is too much!
No, that's not what I meant to do.
Actually, you know what, that's okay.
That works.
Okay, I'm gonna...
Oh, you are so evil.
Can I just...
No, I can't run past.
No, no, no, no, no.
Please, yes, yes.
I am I I am pressing dodge and I guess it's not fast enough for the game standards and it's so frustrating it's so frustrating no that's gonna turn into a but
I'm losing my absolute marbles please stop stop this oh my god this is just horrible I think I'm dead.
Oh my gosh.
Please die!
Why are you so tanky?
No, you can't pass through them.
Okay, good.
It's dead.
Jeez.
Because the pathway is blocked until you kill them.
It's so... it's torturous.
Especially because the thing like spawns enemies, but then it's also so tanky itself.
Ugh, they didn't give me any weapons.
I used my toolkit.
Evil.
Like actually evil.
um which way uh where am i actually i don't even know where i am wait oh i can go this way actually hold on before that oh yeah that's what i want to check for yeah yeah oh crowbar my beloved and an ammo okay oh wait let's just save crowbar oh my god oh my god
I'm so tired.
Is there...
I could ask for more sanity.
Eco.
Die!
Die, bitch!
Oh, I got her.
And I get a knife!
Okay, Gam.
Wait, why am I focused on that?
Wait, you're gonna turn into...
Right?
Or no?
I saw...
Okay, that's...
I was like, I saw something to grab.
What if I just went this way instead?
What's this?
Oh!
Shimizu Hinako!
Last in wearing colored uniform, colored skirt.
This tail of disappearance.
Left hole met with wearing a...
On
the right way.
Yes, we are.
Die!
Oh, I didn't have her.
Oh, my gosh.
Another sickle.
Let's do that.
I don't like the slow weapons.
I'm a missing person.
Why?
Oh, my God.
Hedge.
Oh, no, no, no.
Oh god, please, no!
No, not the titty monster again!
I'm tired!
I'm tired of the titty monster!
I'm tired of this life!
Why are there three of them?
It's too much!
I never thought I would say too much booba, but there's a first for everything, I suppose.
Do I have enough?
Leave me alone.
Dodge?
There we go.
I just barely...
Stop.
I don't want to look at that.
Oh my god, there's another thing!
There's another monster!
Wait, when did I lose my...
Aw, man.
Is this sickle, buddy?
Ouch.
Ouch, ouch.
Ouch,
ouch.
Please.
Okay, that's just an explodey one.
Oh, no.
That's not an explodey one.
Wait, wait, wait.
Not him.
This!
Oh shit.
Oh shit, oh shit.
Okay, we got her.
Holy cow.
I think that's another weapon right there.
What is this?
Crowbar!
I'll take it.
We love Crowbar.
We love it.
Crowbar, Crowbar.
It's like, almost like a boss rush, but there's not bosses.
It's just annoying guys.
What's happening?
Oh.
Did I go the wrong way?
Yeah, just teddy monsters.
Mob rush.
Yeah, that's the word.
My arm!
Uh-oh.
Wait a second.
It's like, can I go?
Don't be stupid.
You're being really rude.
What?
The arm is...
The hair has grown so much.
She's so creepy.
The path of self-preservation.
I refuse.
So did we just kill...
Hinako?
Shimizu Hinako?
Now we are just Hinako?
God, I can feel it.
The bunny ears live.
Congrats on clearing the gauntlet.
A section is always the worst to go through.
Thank you!
Thanks, Cake!
Yeah, no spoilers.
Oh, yeah, I remember this part, this place.
You'd think he'd at least let her change.
Yeah, just follow his lead.
She's like, I don't know this ritual.
What's going on?
What are we doing?
Hidako is controlled by her arm and jeans.
Liquid Hidako.
Shimizu Hidako lives on through this arm.
Getting married overseas.
B-row.
I was thinking.
I was like, she feels like a foreigner.
Right.
She's just kind of like looking at the person and be like, Oh, okay, okay, I'll do that.
Huh?
You look at the voice, but Cam Clark.
Oh, oh, gosh.
I hope none of you have the tropophobia.
Oh, gross.
Oh, ew.
Oh,
my God.
It's so nasty.
Oh my gosh.
Yeah, don't look.
I'll tell you when the triple phobia part is over.
I think it's over.
What do you call that?
Oh my gosh.
She means to hear that go.
Do you like my fox bass, Kinnako?
Like her chula.
Yeah, that's what she do.
Do the flowers sprout everywhere she walks?
Wait, that's beautiful!
What do you spot?
Other spots?
spider lilies, right?
Oh my gosh!
Oh, just kidding.
It reminds me of that one like, I guess, I don't know what to call it, beast in, uh, in, um, Mononokehime, Princess Mononokehime.
I agree!
This is an improvement!
Don't mind the globs of flesh.
Just, uh...
Look, and we match!
No wonder she loves pink so much.
She painted the whole town pink.
What is that?
Oh, no!
Don't go that way!
Oh!
Wait, what's happening?
Oh, gosh.
Wait.
Can I soul siphon still?
Yeah.
Oh!
Ouch!
I thought I killed you.
There we go.
How do I get home?
To the... Okay, I head to the left.
But first...
Oh, okay, I can't even go this way.
I keep seeing... I kept looking at that bandage and I'm like, I just want to pick it up.
Don't go that way.
Ma'am, there's meat blobs blocking everywhere.
I don't think I have a choice.
Even the well.
What's there to drink?
Meat!
What are you supposed to do in a situation like that?
Become a monster, but you're still...
Yeah, it's like...
We're a monster, but I'm still like a little clumsy because I'm like, Where am I?
I know.
I'm a little lost.
Oh, okay.
I thought I heard a...
Oh my gosh!
Sorry, I'm just making sure...
Can we go this way?
Is there anything over here?
Wow.
Artwork?
The bandage.
And?
A dried carcass.
Wood!
It's locked.
have to what we don't have to worry about weapons anymore wait this is so nice i feel like part of that is always my concern in these types of games where i'm like i'm like ah can i can i get
can i get a new weapon in time you know am i gonna get the weapon that i want
Yeah, oh, whoops, that's not my MS Press.
My bad.
Yeah, durability always scares me.
Makes you really kind of like, oh, do I need to run?
Do I need to...
It's the very...
It's the very the survival horror aspect.
Mr. Potsdam would love this play.
The new version of Bloodboard is weird, but cool.
Oh, yeah.
No, this is DMC-6.
What are you talking about?
Is there still a...
Is there a shrine here to save?
Yes, there is.
The music, though, is so sad.
Like, it just sounds sad.
Furry may cry.
Nice.
That's how you know, like, there's gonna be a big old boss battle at the end, because it's still giving you a lot.
Oh no, my dog!
My dog!
Wait, I thought I saw something over here.
Am I crazy?
Yes, I am.
Sorry.
I got it!
Oh wait, actually, I'm sorry.
I just noticed I got the dried carcass.
I'm gonna go offer that too.
Sorry, we're emptying our inventory.
I might even, since I got the Emma, I might actually upgrade eventually.
Is it something else?
Like I feel like we could get the health.
We definitely could get the health.
Might be able to get the stamina.
Maybe.
Hinako just killed Hinako.
It's pretty sad.
It is sad.
Poor baby girl.
What if I just walk past you?
What if I don't check?
Oh, it forces me?
Wait, what do you say anyway?
Wait, what do you say?
Ah!
Oh my gosh, oh my gosh!
Stupid.
Yeah!
Soul Siphon you?
Nice.
I hear another one.
Wait, why isn't it... Oh, there we go.
I was like, why is it not... Focus?
on you yeah yeah so siphon no i missed what she she probably just says don't go that way again if i had to guess we're like don't go home don't do it don't go home what are you doing stupid good stupid girl she says bitch turn around that's what she says That's exactly it.
I actually am a localizer.
I translated that part.
She says something about not being able to stay the way she is now.
That's so sad.
Wait, hold on.
Sorry, I'm... I'm definitely...
Okay, nothing.
Oh, see?
I'm definitely being a little loot goblin right now.
I'm sorry.
We'll go home, we'll go home.
Look at him!
Look, it's so beautiful, though!
I don't blame her.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, okay.
Oh, it's this guy.
Okay.
We are close.
If we can, like, bait her over here.
I don't want to get both involved, is the issue.
I want to be able to go Yeti mode to defeat you.
Can I?
Can you please let me do that?
What?
Are you following me down here?
Fine.
Oh, I missed.
I missed.
How could you miss?
Oh, oops.
Dodge, dodge.
Oh, wait.
I have no stamina.
Turn around, you big dummy.
Oh, wow.
Wait, I took him out so easily.
strong now.
Dang, okay.
I'm insane now.
Insano mode.
Oh, I missed again.
So embarrassing.
Dodge.
No!
Yeah, get them both at the same time!
Yeah!
Can I soul siphon this one?
Okay.
Nice.
I was gonna say, wait, can I go in here?
That'd be kind of crazy.
Marriage buff?
Oh gosh, stinking couples, man.
They're all, like, they get married once and they just make it their whole personality, you know?
Oh, are you still...
Oh.
Why is she a rabbit?
with a werewolf arm.
If you could be anything that your little mind imagines, what do you think you would be?
A rabbit with a Yeti arm?
Most people choose that option.
Most people choose rabbit with a Yeti arm.
science shows that 99 95 sorry i don't want to exaggerate it 95 percent of people choose a rabbit with a yeti arm we're
just doing it for fun now nine out of ten dentists sorry i just realized i went in a circle because i'm silly for absolute silliness right now i like how only the shrines have like nothing even the flowers don't grow at all on them it's cool and we have some antique comb
oh we can do stamina I don't know what do you guys think the remaining 5% choose Yeti with a rabbit arm does this make her more attractive to Fox Boys possibly so take notes everybody anyone looking to get yourself a foxy man.
Or a foxman.
It's, uh,
it's just one of those things.
Noted.
Not a fox lady?
I'm really not quite sure.
What do you have to say this time?
You won't be able to stay as you are now.
Takizo, thank you so much for the Ten!
You did Oh my gosh, oh my gosh, they're coming from all over Oh, oops Oh Wait, hold on I'm gonna go sicko mode
Is that it?
No, of course not Oh, I can't Oh, okay
Oh, we lost it
Oh, maybe I used it too early.
Uh-oh.
I used it too...
Oh, I used it too early, you guys!
I think I used it too early!
Ouch, ouch, ouch.
Wait.
I used it too early.
I went to Soul Siphon that.
Woo!
Holy moly!
Wait,
wait, wait, wait, wait.
Wait, please.
Be kind.
Oh, that was close.
Oh my gosh.
Wait, I'm trying to get out of here.
Thank you.
Oh!
Oh, I was doing so well.
I was doing so well.
Oh, dang it.
I thought that got him.
I'm not gonna lie.
Okay, this guy should give us a big siphon, though, right?
Lots of souls.
Oh, yeah.
Delicious.
I kinda...
I'm not gonna lie.
I understand.
I messed that one up.
Wait, what can we get rid of?
I guess.
I feel like we need the chocolate now more than ever.
You know?
I don't want to get rid of my Inazushi.
We're fine, I think.
We're okay.
I did fine.
But I released, I pulled my devil trigger too early, I think.
It's okay, though.
We made it.
Oh, is this home?
Before we go in, though, I haven't really, like, looked over here.
I think I did before.
Oh!
Oh, wait, this is my home.
Wait, whose house is it?
I was just about to enter a stranger's property.
But I'm gonna do it now, anyway.
Oh, there's nothing here.
Wow, it's so beautiful.
You think a cutscene's gonna happen?
Okay, hold on, guys.
Hold on, mom.
Hold on, dad.
Oh, there's nothing over here.
It's all goop.
It's all big old meat goop.
Do you recognize me?
It's me!
Hinako!
I've grown.
through a the kids call this a growth spurt whoa now that's a growth spurt
Quit your crocodile tears.
I'm gonna turn you into a puddle.
Puddle them.
Make them into a puddle.
When did we get two arms?
Get gooped!
The path of exultation.
I accept.
The
Ooh, regular Hinako.
Wait, this is Shimizu Hinako.
My doll!
Help Shimizu Hinako, please!
Oh, my crowbar!
Oh, wait, no, no, no.
Wait, I'm in this world, but I don't have Yeti powers?
Uh-oh.
Oh my gosh, how much more is there?
Proceed.
How much more is there?
No point in turning back now.
Almost at the end?
I'm being a little, like I said, a little loot goblin.
This is what women's dreams are like.
Yeah, they're either this or they're sexy.
Or this and sexy.
A willow wisp!
Good to see you guys.
Oh my gosh, it looks just like you.
Look how cute.
Hi.
Oh, it looks just like you.
You guys are in the game, you didn't tell me?
Pretty,
so pretty.
Oh, I remember.
I've been through all of this!
Yeah!
With all...
Oh no, these things are still here?
Wait, I'm gonna lose it.
I thought I heard...
I thought I heard it.
Like I thought I heard the chains.
Maybe I'm imagining it.
Maybe it's PTSD.
Or maybe it actually happened just to be like, hey, remember.
Remember what you've been through.
Oh no, it just saved.
Oh!
Yeah!
Oh, no stamina.
Oh, shoot.
What a terrible time to not have stamina.
Oh, we're so good.
Rip and tear, rip and tear!
So much kudzu.
Allale.
Wait, we have so much stuff.
What's here?
Toolkit!
Wait, that's huge.
Divine water even.
Wow, they're just like, you thirsty?
You hungry?
You need repairs?
You good?
You good girl?
So now we go, I guess we go through all these areas again, and we fight.
This was long, though.
We can't go through everything, right?
We went through a lot of stuff.
Who?
Wait, who's in my way?
Oh, gosh.
It's this guy.
This bozo.
It's like a boss rush.
Oh, gosh.
I wanted to get you first!
Oh, I did.
Ah!
Oh, a snack down before you smack down.
I hate this.
Haven't I gone through enough?
For real though.
Like, it's mob rush after mob rush.
It's kind of horrible.
Like, why am I doing this again?
I just did it!
I just did one!
You good?
You good, bro?
Is it good?
Oh, okay, we got him.
Of course.
Of course, of course.
Oh, dang it.
Try the dodge.
Ha, ha, ha, ha, ha.
Sledgehammer.
No, no.
Give me...
Yeah, I know they say beggars can't be choosers, but they give me something else.
Let's get...
Dude, I think maybe two of those would be better than one full heal.
What's this?
Oh, another toolkit.
Oh, wait.
We have more toolkits.
Let's just heal.
What's it?
Oh, yeah, let's heal it.
There we go.
I know we're kind of, you know, at the mercy of...
What is that?
Oh, thank you.
The game, but...
Surely there's nothing else around here, right?
Yeah.
Yeah, heavy weapons will be, like, really difficult.
Just some floor pills.
Where's the...
Save.
Awesome.
Okay.
Alright.
Yeah, baby!
Okay, okay.
Enshrine.
Wait.
What is here, anyway?
A lot of stuff.
Like, everything.
Oh my gosh.
Everything is here.
I want to I want to I don't want to I don't want to sell anything
Wait I still don't know which one to get though Health or stamina I feel like if you have enough stamina You can just dodge forever We don't need health You know This one like I feel like we probably have Enough health items I'm gonna keep the Inari Zushi I'm gonna keep the She's thinking like a Souls player.
Stamina does kill stuff faster.
That's so true.
I probably won't use it.
I'm going to be honest.
I'm going to try and use the chocolate.
Wait, I figured I would have my arm.
Wait, if I don't have my arm, do I need my sanity?
Wait a second.
Did I play myself?
Did I just play myself?
What?
the chocolate no i don't have my arm in the final battle use the chocolate oh you do use it for focus that's so true that's so true i i thought i would have my why would you give me a yeti arm if i can't use it in the boss fight it's messed up that's messed up is wrong It's wrong!
Well, hold on.
We'll do this.
I will save.
And then I will pray.
If I find that I am needing more health, then I can load and I will do that.
You know what I mean?
I will just redo it.
More stamina, more stamina, more stamina.
We could get more sanity if we had enough Emma.
I feel like they should give you one in this room.
I can't even draw an Omamori.
And also, I'm going to change out my...
Omamori.
I'm going to change out from the...
Well, actually, let's see what the fight is like first.
Because I don't know.
There might be like...
What's it called?
Manicans that I have to fight to.
Freely decreases focus charging time.
Increase max stamina.
Okay, we'll...
I'll keep it for like that for now.
You carry your upgrades and stuff in the new game plus, so that's why they don't drop so many.
No, that makes total sense.
Makes sense.
I get it.
Well, I get it.
I'm going to eat that.
I'm going to grab that.
The water...
Hold on.
I've never used the water, so I don't remember what it does.
It gives us sanity.
Okay, we'll do that.
Is that everything in here?
I...
I think.
It is.
Okay.
I can't tell if I'm at a boss fight yet or not.
Is this it?
Is it?
They're here?
Shimizu Hinako.
So cute.
Wait, what is this?
yeah I'll take that and what else a bandage I think I'm good even more stuff there's more they give me more things I love these breezy naive slice of life copies the
dolls like tear take this knife wait another save huh huh okay I'm The bottom one is the save where I got stamina.
Okay.
I hope you know that Konami requires you to write a five-page essay on what you thought of the combat.
Yeah!
What I learned in...
What I learned in Silent Hill F is...
Oh, she's going through where...
She did all the rituals and stuff.
Making my way downtown Walking slow Taking in all the sides
I love this montage Of like her going around Seeing everything
Maybe it's supposed to be more impactful Because it's actually Shimizu Hinako Seeing everything rather than just Hinako But I don't know.
It's the deal with the dogs.
So there's a fox tron.
Is this it?
Is this where we do the fight?
Or am I the minister?
Am I ordaining this marriage?
Is my sister the final boss?
Oh,
she's got the thing on her...
The brooch, though.
Are
those the red pills I've been taking?
Uh-oh.
Wait, should I have not been if...
Should I have not been taking those?
Oh, geez.
It's the pill's fault.
Rupro.
I know there's, like, conditions for, like, unlocking other parts of the game, like, the other endings.
I wonder if one of them is not taking the pills, like, not using them at all.
Oh my god.
Maybe?
No spoilers!
You're forced into this ending on your first playthrough.
Yeah, because you wouldn't know.
Oh my gosh, it's like those mists at theme parks when it's summertime.
It feels so good.
Oh!
like screams?
That's so freaky.
You take the bill's chat disappears.
No, don't leave me.
I'll be so lonely.
Hinako, please.
Oh, wait.
We're already in a fight.
Oh, my God.
Shidomuku!
Whoa.
I've learned the art of the dodge.
Maybe.
Oh.
Ouch.
Oh, I pressed dodge.
And I did, baby.
Oh, ouch.
Ouch, ouch, ouch.
Dang.
Ooi.
Wooy!
Oh, dang it.
I timed it all wrong.
Yeah, stab her.
Ouch.
And don't get stabbed yourself.
Woo!
Let's let her stamina...
Just kidding!
Oh.
Oh, oh, nice.
Yeah, aren't you gonna kill me?
Dummy?
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
Oh, the flowers.
Ooh, we're getting into darkness.
Oh, my gosh.
So scary.
Oh, let me out.
Uh-oh.
Okay.
Um.
Oh, no, no.
Ouch!
Why didn't I dodge that?
I'm so stupid.
Wait, please.
Lock on.
Let's get away.
Oh, ouch.
Whoa!
Oh, it's like hurting me.
Ouch!
Where am I supposed to go?
Oh, you're supposed to...
Oh my...
Oh, what?
Oh!
Okay.
Let's go?
Ouch, ouch.
Oh my gosh.
Ouch, ouch, ouch, ouch.
The moveset is crazy!
Oh, geez.
More bandages, please?
Wait, I'm like healing too.
Oh, gosh!
Oh, gosh.
Sorry, I'm still taking the pills.
Ow!
Oh, wait.
Uh, uh, ah, ah!
Wait, do I just run here?
Oh my gosh, wait!
Ah!
I don't know what to do here!
I just die.
I just end
up...
You just run away?
Ugh.
I do end up, like, healing, though, which is kind of cool.
Oh, shoot.
Shit, shit, shit, shit.
Oh, oh, wait.
She's got my dodge.
Hey, you can't have my dodge.
It's, like, my dodge.
You can't have that.
I wish the camera angle...
wasn't so weird.
Why did I learn that move?
Oh, spinny arm, spinny arm.
Oh, I dodged right into her.
That's so funny.
It's not funny.
It's funny.
Isn't that, like, so quirky?
Wait, I have...
Okay, I have one weapon left.
Hey!
Okay, I'm running.
I'm...
Ah!
I'm running!
I don't know what to do!
I'm confused!
I'm running!
I'm- I don't know what to do!
Oh, If I get away farther.
Oh, I see.
I see.
Okay.
Ouch!
Ouchie!
Whoa!
My gosh!
Yeah, they're safe spots and noticing that not...
Like...
That...
Oh my god.
Please!
Ma'am!
I need you to...
Wait.
Is that it?
Oh!
Phase two?
Uh-oh.
Wait, I think the Fox guy is gonna be kind of angry at me.
Right.
He's gonna be like, you killed my wife!
You killed my wife!
Yeah,
feel that.
Oh my gosh, my trauma hearing these sounds.
Our crowbar is all...
Be love!
Wait, I have to fight these two.
Oh my god, please, no more!
Please!
Get me out of here.
I like how there's...
Are those pills all over the ground?
Wait, that's messed up.
Oh my god, there's pills everywhere!
Oh my gosh.
Wait, I'm lost.
Oh, just kidding.
Um, okay.
I kind of want to grab all of them.
really tempting it's so tempting
no way please let me say i can get run past okay good
oh my gosh we're running
Everything's falling apart.
Wait, what was that?
Oh.
I thought it was a letter.
Oh my gosh.
It's insanity.
Wait, am I just...
Am I just running in circles?
Oh, wait, wait, wait.
Okay.
Oh, that scared me.
This guy's still trying to attack me while I'm running.
Oh
my gosh.
Wait, that's insane!
Oh, we're speeding now?
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa!
Wait, the visuals are so cool!
Like it's so stretched.
Massive pills.
500 FOV, me and Minecraft.
Why does the shrine have like a police alarm system?
Is this phase two?
What?
Oh, I got it!
Hippie!
I understand why they're like, no, no, you must play the game again.
No, no, no.
How many endings?
Wait, I think I asked this before.
I think people said like three endings or something.
My singletch face, thank you so much for the five.
Good to thank you.
Aw.
Four.
Four endings.
Four endings plus one joke ending.
Ah, okay.
I think people said the...
I think I remember what people said the joke ending was.
I feel like...
I can't give a proper...
Uh...
Not review, but my proper thoughts on the story itself, because I obviously have not seen like the other endings and the true ending, you know?
But...
I have seen many people complaining about...
The amount of combat...
And that I do understand.
and they won a four this game has a wonderful story but a lot of filler because you have to replay it a lot yeah it's fun watching it get lost with a gloom goblin thank you close credits scene add some context okay cool yeah I like the story but the fact that it's and I like You know,
obviously I've been like raving about the visuals.
Um, I definitely felt like the combat would get more cumbersome, just kind of like, okay, like this, this again, then like, scary, you know, but...
I don't mind being...
I don't mind playing a game multiple times to get all the endings.
Don't get me wrong.
Yonegawa-Niori Kenkei-Honbue, Kenkawa-Nioui Kenkawa-nui-jian-no-higisha-to-omowa-shiki-joice-neighborhood.
One of the men, one of the one.
One of the men, Kenkei-Norui-Kenkei-honbue.
One of the people, Kenkei-Honbue.
One of the victims are used, but the city's history is not found to be found.
Kenkei-Honbueh-higisha-hikishe-hikishe-hikishe-hikishe 20 years.
His height is 160 cm.
The dark line.
The dark blue.
It is okay.
Oh,
her parents!
Change!
What has said in her 20s?
Love the setting, the story and the characters, but as someone who enjoys Souls games, the combat is not what I wanted out of Silent Hill.
Yeah, I get that.
I get that.
Silent Hill F was the friends we killed a lot.
the way it's a studio that did your 3d yeah it is it is they're amazing they're so they're so awesome
um watch the other endings if you don't plan on playing again i asked about that before and people said that thing little things change throughout the story so i don't think it's really a thing just watch the ending, you know?
Perhaps let's not do ibuprofen together.
This soundtrack is so beautiful.
Oh my gosh.
So, I, going back to that other super chat that was saying like, you know, um, the gameplay is not what you wanted from a Silent Hill.
I actually, honestly, when I, I was playing this, it's not the combat itself that bothered me so much.
Surprisingly, it was actually the amount of it.
I just don't like playing video games.
No, just kidding.
I think I just don't want to play video games.
I think it was like...
Yeah, they should be able to...
They should let you run more.
The fact that I was forced into some of those fights with, like, the most annoying of creatures is what is so frustrating about it.
But, um...
But...
Where was I going with this?
Oh, I mentioned this before, but I saw someone tweet about how, like, I played on story mode.
And, you know, it was still challenging, you know?
Too much titty monster.
I never thought I would say that before.
The gauntlets kind of sucked.
Yeah, yeah.
Resident Evil 9, Silent Hill, F...
But...
Bust...
God, wait, what?
I feel like we needed some ranged weapons.
I'm not gonna lie.
That's what I meant.
The amount of combat, not really the combat itself.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Congrats on adding another completed game.
to the list.
Oh, thank you.
That's right.
You're right.
Huara-u!
Welcome to Bamboo Chef.
Thank you so much.
Thank you, thank you.
Like a gun.
Yeah, we need a gun.
We need to not go to go full American.
Red, white, and blue.
I feel like I could think of something.
I don't know.
Not a gun, per se.
Maybe like super powered slingshot i don't know it's it's fantasy
but uh i guess a bow would work yeah yeah a flamethrower easy
but yeah um i played on story mode and it was still quite challenging i feel like there's a bit of a
gamer i'm uh so i feel like with someone i feel like for a lot of people they could probably get uh pretty tied up in some of these parts of the game phil thank you so much for the 50 gift thank you thank you thank you so much
re4 has a lot of combat but it's way better and a lot more gratifying because he get guns.
Yeah, guards.
Thank you for the warning, though.
Opening cutscene and New Game Plus changes a good amount if you want to taste...
Oh, really?
Good job, Minto.
And New Game Plus skips the middle section entirely.
So it takes about five hours to run to the end.
Oh, really?
But the combat gauntlet is still there.
New Game Plus!
Oh, sorry.
I didn't see what the achievements were.
I played on hard because I wanted a challenge, but I regretted that in the end came such a slog see i that's what i feel like i feel like oh my gosh would you even need to play this game on hard because it would just be so much no recommend silent hill 3 that's actually i have played silent hill 3 i think that was my first silent hill i'm not gonna lie um but i played it when i was a wee wisp so
I don't quite remember a lot of it I remember like obviously Heather that was Heather right am I getting her name right I remember I remember in the like going to the amusement park area I remember of course you started the mall main issue is the force combat yes yeah early game you can run away no problem but the end you have to you have eight back-to-back force combat arenas with mini bosses you have to get through yeah yeah Watch the ending on YouTube right now.
No.
Oh, I remember the one room you go into in Silent Hill 3 that would lock you in there and you just die and you don't know not to go into that room.
And I really thought they were going to do that in this game.
So I would like go into a room and be like,
yeah, the mirror, the mirror, the mirror.
room yes oh my gosh i really thought they were gonna do it though i was like don't trust anyone don't trust anyone i've ever played the silent hill the room i have not played that one actually
well i didn't need the extra health woohoo look at that they have the pills there let's mess up
Coming home to roost.
Drown in a bottomless pit of self-doubt.
Mood?
Just watching the endings.
Won't give you proper context since a lot of info is revealed and recontextualize along the way.
The Ryukishi special!
They're gonna be like, here's some notes and only believe the stuff that's written and read.
wow it's completely taken over we can watch the we can watch the what's it called I like how I click continue it doesn't even give me the option to load one of my older saves
lost in the fog stronger enemies and less resources for people looking for tense combat there's already a hard mode and then you're going to give like the super hard mode.
Insane.
But we can watch the opening cutscene.
And I did do the puzzles on hard.
most of them were easy.
View endings tells you what you need to do.
Wait, tells you what you need to do.
It does.
The game needs like two more unique enemy types.
I agree.
I I seeing I do I think it's fun that you see the mannequins change like they become more like bloomed and that's kind of cool but wasn't there one unless it's like a boss for one of the other endings but there was there was there was an enemy I remember seeing before the game came out that had like flowers blooming from it and it wait one okay thank you so much for that look at super why thank you thank you so much
the steel case cover let me see let me see what the steel case cover was
Silent Hill F Steelcase Cover Uh
No I don't think so Um I remember it was It was so beautiful That's why hold on Silent Hill F Monsters I'm just gonna look it up It was like so pretty though I remember it had like I think like bulky arms and like flowers growing from it.
I was like very pink.
The short game has a really good flower enemy.
Maybe it's that then.
Like I feel like the arms were like wrapped.
Like they had like not like like black tape around it or something.
I might be making that up though.
Don't quote me on that.
Wait I found it!
The Sakura head!
Wait!
Yeah!
Sakura, I guess it's called Sakura head.
Wait, where is that?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Silent Hill's short message.
Timeless!
Stay cringe and free.
Happy birthday!
Thank you so much.
I'm sorry.
I will be streaming on your birthday tomorrow.
Happy, happy birthday!
Silent Hill is a short message.
Oh, dang it.
it i was really looking forward to seeing it it's from an entirely different game i'm such an idiot me not doing my research wait i think i remember the short message was like
i think i remember it was like all the notes and stuff right or whatever
and there was just like you're ugly you're stupid the bullying messages, right?
Yeah, a lot of notes.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, okay, okay.
Okay, I definitely did not play that, obviously.
Dang, but I kind of want to play it just to see Sakura had.
Such a pretty design.
It's like so, so, so beautiful.
Okay.
So, wait, didn't take the red capsules?
Purified the sacred sword or didn't obtain it?
I don't remember that.
Obtain the Agura Nohotei Sama.
Didn't take the red capsules.
Obtain the unpurified sacred sword.
There's a sacred sword.
Complete two different full endings.
Mystery, mystery, mystery.
Oh, this is the...
This is the...
Listen to all the UFO radio broadcasts.
There were broadcasts?
Found all three of the great space invasion movie posters in order.
After listening to the UFO radio broadcast, found the great space invasion movie review after fulfilling the conditions above.
This is like the joke ending, right?
Where like, it's space.
The sacred sword doesn't show up until New Game Plus.
Ah!
That makes sense then.
The Ibo ending.
Yeah, UFO hunting.
Space Wars ending.
Oka.
UFO, UFO, UFO, UFO is the true ending, I believe.
Okay, let's watch this then.
We'll go with the Navy.
You full ending, real ending.
The real.
I'd be honest, it's been a couple weeks since we saw the opening scene before, so...
I don't quite remember what will be different, but...
I'm going to eat some chips, though.
I guess this is good though to rewatch kind of everything though, right?
She's got the brooch!
What does that do?
What does the brooch do?
You can open new boxes.
Open some doors that were locked before.
Sorry, I meet
my trips.
I'll give it to you.
I love how this like song sounds so silent hill but also obviously the setting is in Japan so it's Japanese too but like just the guitar strumming is so it's so good yeah they nailed it like
you hear this and you think it's a Silent Hill song it's so good I love it
sorry can you hear me crunching sorry I'm eating some veggie chips I basically have like a giant bag of them
oh my gosh wait I just realized I was so concerned with eating earlier I forgot to do the mood lighting on on myself I'm sorry just notice I forgot gotta
save there
whoa I also think it's pretty stinky that you have to fight the dad again I guess well and you don't even get to kill it essentially just walks away
Wait, wasn't her face?
Where's her face?
Oh, yeah, her mom went after her before.
Wow.
Oh, yeah, the mom chases you the first time.
Huh.
This scene is so stressful.
It is, yeah.
That's, okay.
That's like, that's, it's subtle enough to where, like, you have to kind of be like, wait, whoa, whoa, oh, oh, oh, that's cool.
I like it, I like it.
You can also read about the final boss in your journal now.
Oh, really?
Oh, wait.
This.
Wait, I saw you.
I saw you.
I...
Where'd you go?
You!
The pain of my existence.
The monster that my father turned into.
It acts the same way he did when he let his anger get the best of him.
It was the curse of fatherhood that made my dad appear human.
This form, his true form, must have been hidden underneath all along.
The monster that my mother turned into.
Not even sure she realized what happened to her.
Always being humiliated and abused.
Her twisted ideal of happiness.
There's no way that she was a human to begin with.
Wait, where's the final box?
Under Dark Shrine?
Oh, teddy monster.
Wait, I don't see it.
I'll have to walk out of it.
Ah.
An intimidating monster that appears in Shidomuku, a traditional white wedding kimono.
It uses their grand fox arm to compel others to obey.
It looks down on me and denies my existence.
But at the same time, it pities me like it thinks it's better than...
It thinks it's better.
Better than me or something.
Don't look down on me.
You're no better.
The final boss is marriage.
Oh my god.
Wait, are all the portraits messed up still?
Oh, wait.
Yeah.
Oh, no.
No, they're back to normal.
Marriage hate!
Well, thank you, guys.
Guys, I'll decide.
Maybe eventually I'll be kind of like, I'm so curious.
Obviously, if I play it on my own time, I'll play it on my own time.
But there might be like, I don't have time.
And I'm like, I'm so curious.
I want to, I want to experience the other ending.
So, oh, sorry.
Never say never about me doing the other ones.
You know, it might just be a while though.
Dargo, thank you so much.
Way to kick hash and add another winner to your list.
Thank you.
Thank you so much for the for the akasuba.
Is that a gummy worm in there?
I had to take a break before coming back.
Understandable.
There's definitely some compilations on YouTube that summarize the different endings.
I believe that too.
I believe it.
But this was a lot of fun.
I did, like I said, ultimately I enjoyed it despite the frustration.
Rating bits.
Ultimately, I thought it was fine.
So, ah, fake deal.
Thank you also for the Akashima.
It's a great deal.
It's all those endless mom medals.
Thank you.
Thank you so much.
There's an achievement for beating Shinomuku without dying.
I wonder.
Wait, but I did die.
And then I was brought back.
Dang.
Unless that didn't count.
I did get three achievement.
Let me see if I don't think I got it though.
I can't actually these are all so like these are so no I don't think I got it
it's funny because you can actually die a few times eventually they revive you with 99 pills wait if you were doing a pillless run would that ruin it that would be horrible
wait that would be the worst imagine you get through the whole game taking no pills and then you just suck at the boss and they're like shoving it down your throat that would be the worst how many completed games are we at I guys I need to lock in I just I'm gonna say that now we're not doing so hot and by we it's me I'm not doing so hot.
Wait, open the...
Open.
Why won't you open my document?
Play the games.
There we go.
Um...
10...
Oh, no.
We're 11.
November 1st, 2025.
Silent Hill F.
We'll take it.
We got an ending.
Um...
I need, oh gosh, why doesn't Google Sheets, you know how like in Excel you can highlight a bunch of lines and it will tell you how many there are?
Like one, two, three, four, five, six, seven, eight, nine, ten, eleven, twelve, thirteen, fourteen, fifteen, sixteen, seventeen, nineteen, nineteen games I need to complete.
I need to complete.
We could probably do some, like, one-offs, you know?
Maybe.
I think.
We could do some, like, one-off games.
Time to start marathoning two-hour-long games.
Exactly, exactly.
So.
I have it at 33 completed.
17 remaining.
Really?
What?
We must compare our lists.
Tyre plays some visual novels and hold the fast forward button.
Google Sheets does count.
Look at the bottom right.
No, it literally is not showing any number for me.
Here, I'll show you my list.
I'll show you my list.
I'll even show you that there's no number.
Wait.
Oh wait, why did it just show up?
Oh my gosh, it did.
I adjusted my screen and it showed up.
I adjusted the window.
But anyway, I'll send you my...
Here's my list that I have.
Perhaps I missed some.
You can tell me on Twitter.
You can yell at me and be like...
Me too!
You actually did this one too.
This is my list.
It's so organized, isn't it?
Homete.
Praise me for being so organized.
Sly Cooper Games are chill and easy to beat.
Not quite one-off, but definitely worth looking at.
Oh, yeah, that'd be fun.
Harvester!
Okay.
Wait, when did I beat that?
I like having it all my ducks in a row.
La, la, la, la, la.
Harvester was four days ago.
That was...
Hold on.
You're going to hear it.
October 27th.
10.
27.
Harvester.
Okay.
So we're at...
32 games.
Wait, but someone said 33.
Fake Nate said 33.
I'm not counting Visage.
I'm not counting.
Doki did that What a list Brings back so many happy memories Watching your streams Yeah Honestly it's really fun to look at too Because I'm like wow I did so much this year Wow Wow Starting from January We completed a game It may I was going to say we completed a game every month But I did not complete a game in June I messed up.
Transformers Devastation.
Oh my gosh, please tell me I defeated.
I beat that in June.
Is the Mint plush gonna be available again?
Which one?
The Fumo?
Maybe.
The Small Minto?
I would like to have those available again someday.
Maybe in my next merch drop.
This little nerd in her video game spreadsheet.
Adorable!
Wait.
Transformers Devastation.
Oh, I didn't put that in.
Wait, when did I beat that?
Mint Phantom Transformers.
Brrrrbrrbrrbrrbrrr.
Which one is...
I think this one is...
Hold on.
Checking the days.
February.
Okay, it was February.
February 21st.
Oh, I really did miss it.
Transformers Devastation.
Okay, then I'm not doing so bad.
I just have...
Wait, the number disappeared again, you guys.
Oh, I see why.
I see why.
Okay.
I was highlighting the empty columns, the empty rows.
Because it didn't have anything, it wasn't counting it.
I get it now.
I have 33 games.
out of 50.
Super liminal!
Oh my gosh!
Wait!
Wait, seriously?
I've been pulling the spreadsheets like...
Love the Jurassic Park arcade stream so much.
All the silly quarter bits during it were adorable.
I'm glad you liked that.
That was... I wanted to do the arcade game and then I was like, yeah, but I'm gonna like finish it.
So how can I make this more... Like the quarter bits were kind of It was a stroke of inspiration.
I'm glad you guys liked it.
I added Harvester.
Yeah, yeah.
I just added it.
So, wait, what was it super liminal too?
Oh, my gosh.
Please tell me I've finished that in June.
So I can have one game.
Oh, sorry.
One game done every...
No, March.
Dang it.
March 27th.
Ah, okay.
Super liminal.
I think I did that in one stream, though.
I think so.
I think that was a one stream.
One hitter.
I think so.
We love every bit of me for it, Dom.
Thank you.
Okay, let me show my new list now.
New list, new list.
New list.
Yay!
My gosh!
New list plus, yeah.
Wow!
We're at 34 games!
35?
Wait.
So that would be...
Wait, what's 50 minus 34?
Calculator.
50 minus 34.
Wait, is that how many?
1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8, 9, 10, 11, 12, 13, 14, 15, 16.
Yeah.
You're missing a couple.
I don't think so.
No way!
Did you and Barry end up beating Battle Block Leader?
No, we haven't yet.
So I can add that.
We can, yeah, I can add that once.
Once.
I didn't shoot, I didn't, I didn't do peak because, you know, didn't feel right to say that I beat that game.
Oblivion also, I did not beat for sure.
I did not beat Oblivion.
DMCs were especially fun.
Really?
I think so.
Honestly, sometimes I really want to private those streams.
Sometimes I'm like,
Sometimes I think like, man, I,
I, I just, I, you know, I'm, it wasn't, it's not my type of game.
And so I didn't play it very well.
And so sometimes I'll just get comments.
I'll get occasional comments of people just being like, gosh, this is so painful to, to watch.
I didn't see faith.
Oh, how did I miss so many?
no way
oh I didn't but for faith do I count that as one game or how many games do I count that as that's three games right so faith one faith two faith three does that is that okay
three games
wait when did I do that oh my gosh you guys are helping me so much Faith Okay What?
Wait, that was a year ago, you guys It's only for 2025 It's only for 2025 Sorry, sorry These are games completed This year, I wanted to get to 50 games This year Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah It's okay though Good You still were trying.
You were trying to help me out.
I appreciate that so much.
Yeah.
I appreciate it.
Don't worry.
Okay.
So, I'll do my best.
34 games out of 50.
Not bad.
I found your DMC streams great.
They're peak silly.
People are just try-hards.
Yeah, I guess that's, you know.
Henry Stickman is technically four games in one.
Duh!
Mimpy like five games in one stream.
She's correct!
I know!
I'm a gamer!
I think now I feel a little more confident about completing it in the next two months.
I think we can do it.
I think we can, I think we could get through a lot of, a lot of games.
Yeah, games like repo, I saw some people mentioning like Zoo Tycoon and stuff too.
Those don't really have like endings.
It's not really...
This plague ink count that I...
I don't know.
I feel like I want it to be like...
My criteria is a little specific, you know, where it's like...
It must have...
Like an ending, you know?
Like...
I feel like plague ink...
I feel like I can't count...
Like, this plague...
Plague doesn't count as a roguelike, obviously.
But like, you know, games that are kind of repetitive like that...
I'm kind of...
I'm kind of a little more...
specific on the criteria.
So, that's why there are some games that are...
Did you play the new Chilla's art?
The fishing one?
Right now, it's only a demo.
Nemi's vase!
Yeah, I played the fishing demo.
I did do that.
If you go to my stream, if you wanted to watch, the what was it called that's like me playing demo games or something spooky demo sorry that was mine that was my controller spooky demo sometimes up that's a random playing random horror games i played it there that should count right no it was a demo it was a demo but i believe we could do it if you you actually what i'll do is i'll make a members post and i'll say if you have any streams that you think or any games that you think could be beat in one stream um and i would say anything between like three to five hours is doable but you beat the whole demo three to five hours i think is something that is doable for you can even go to six hours yeah you could go to six hours three to six hours for a stream I think so I will make so everybody who has been wanting to suggest your games to me it helps as well if maybe you link either like a steam page or something like that oh actually I don't think you can in a comment huh um yeah just say
the name of it maybe give if you have time like a like a brief description what kind of game it is red dead redemption 2 if you played club penguin and played every mini game in it would that count i don't know tuna would it would you let that count tuna would you
is there a community discord or something There is a fan discord.
I am not in it.
I'm sorry.
So, but you could discuss ideas in there.
You could be like, hey, do you think Pinto would like this game?
So.
Okie dokie.
I'm banned.
I'm banned from it.
Why?
You guys hate me.
You say it.
You say.
You say I hate you.
You hate me.
Can you play Merge Laboobu?
Okay.
I want to play what was that?
What's that like?
Isn't it like Merge Mansion or something?
Mystery Gardenscapes?
Mystery Mansion?
I saw something with Mansion.
It's like all the ads are like the grandma killed somebody but she has a secret.
My mom plays Merge Mansion.
and wait
i've played peggle before but that also doesn't have like a store i well would peggle count okay see this is where it gets a little complicated because okay like i saw someone bring up kukiyomi earlier too like kukiyomi doesn't have like any challenge to beat it you know what i mean like uh i also another criteria is like if it doesn't have a story per se it has to where there is like an a some sort of challenge in beating it it's not just like a you know a thing marathon all eight halo games and halo war halo wars one and two before year end okay
peggle counts but i don't know if it was this year i don't think it was i don't think it was should count if you complete all the levels okay yeah yeah yeah so that would count
okay i'm gonna go for real now guys i'm gonna go eat dinner because i'm so hungry i'm so hungry oh tomato everybody thank you so much for the help with some of the puzzles as well it's like the like the fox one i don't think i would have gotten it without you guys just giving me hints so thank you thank you thank you i will see you when i see you next if you are at us idol festival um what are you doing watching my stream go have fun and enjoy the event what is wrong with you
um if you have a meet and greet with me tomorrow i will see you there and if not then i'll see you either monday my next stream or whenever i stream next whenever you can catch me push for killer is dead it's a weird action game where you unlock weapons by dating ladies okay we'll send that sango put that in the in the in the what's it called hot dog not the hot dog South is here.
Thank you.
Oh my gosh.
I'm playing Meow Tower, which is a P-cross.
Which is a P-cross mobile game.
And right now, the theme is Hot Dog.
I don't know why.
Let's see.
What things have I... What category...
That's the category.
What things have I gotten for Hot Dog?
Hold on.
I've gotten Hot Dog Men.
Hot dog bun Hot dog eating contest Frankfurter Hot dog truck And I still have three more that I need to unlock What's the name of the game?
Meow tower Like meow like a cat
Okay Okay okay what was I saying?
Oh I don't remember Oh I don't remember Oh no I don't remember Sorry
Ah thank you for watching Thanks for the recommendation from y'all tower?
Yeah, of course, do I go.
Ata vita!